on est toujours là quoi qu'il se passe
nous sommes toujours en place en place
toujours en place
quoi qu'il se passe et on est là pour
une énième une énième journée de ce
pitch est féminin en espérant et ben je
sais pas on espère en quoi mais on
l'espère c'est déjà ça en espérant avoir
une belle journée je me suis pas encore
ouvert lé chat je dois faire deux petits
trucs techniques du coup je me suis
emmêlé les pinceaux avec les avec les
réseaux sociaux et avec les navigateurs
mais c'est bon c'est mon et là on est là
et ça c'est bon là je suis je suis à
je suis à une encablure d'y arriver
wen en fait je me suis à ok je me suis
embrouillé avec bon c'est pas grave je
me suis embrouillé avec les navigateurs
sais rien j'ai mis le mauvais navigateur
c'est pas grave ça parle ça va quand
même marché
et c'est le plus important alors rouvre
le chat et puis on va se lancer dans les
matches on va se lancer dans les matches
à ma diagonale déjà qui est là il ya
jazz j'ai raté son message qui est là
aussi et on va aller chercher les deux
chemins les matchs alors qu'est-ce qu'on
suit on va suivre alors al jurf
kosteniuk koné roux tiens on va suivre
kosteniuk au nez rouge est ce que ça
s'est lancé déjà n'ont pas encore quand
même ça pas ok c'est bon mais je suis en
train de bien attendez le chat est sorti
mais je vois pas de message à véria pas
grand monde
je vais checker que ça marche quand même
du coup donc on est parti pour quelques
heures on semble les amis et saluer lieu
chess aujourd'hui gros jour n'est que le
se battent à louey
mais c'est pas moi qui commenterait le
ferez pas là ce soir pour le sol battle
elliott
je ne serai pas là pour le solde battle
il y aura un invité de marque
ceux qui me suivent sur twitter peuvent
peuvent déjà savoir qui commentera ce
soir le seul battle à 20h45
il y aura un invité surprise à ma place
un invité de poids si vous m'avez sur
twitter vous savez qui c'est
c'est pas mvl non on regarde ça ouais on
regardera sahara après bâle à elle joue
pas le premier maintenant mais si vous
c'est sur twitter vous savez déjà qui
s'est exactement exactement rojo sera
c'est super bits ce soir ce soir c'est
super 8 ce qui me remplace y en a marre
de perdre et normalement normalement
avec super vite son parent on part quand
même avec un avantage certain super vite
venons du futur il va il au courant des
résultats de matches il doit savoir
quelle composition il faut mettre donc
normalement normalement ça devrait bien
se passer avec super blitz on va assurer
le coup je perds vite ce sera avec fabre
et puis moi j'en profiterai pour un peu
me reposer ce soir du coup je serai
absent pour la petite pire que des 6 et
6 j'ai fait une vidéo il n'y a pas
longtemps mais qui n'est pas encore
sorti cki super blitz à ta jamais vues
superbes liszt bat apprendre à le
découvrir
tu verras super bis du coup ce soir tu
peux tu peux trouver ya une vidéo sur
youtube déjà super meat si tu tapes je
serai une combien d'heures par semaine
entre 40 et 50
bon une petite position insipide
insipide pas tiens c'est pire que ça
elle va envoyer 5 à attaquer à notre
amie alexandra on va bien l'échiquier ou
pas parce que j'ai eu une petite j'ai
une petite imprécisions techniques mais
ça va il sait que c'est morvan
aujourd'hui huawei au courant elliott
bref super rapide ce qui est évidemment
un héros parce que je suis permise a
quand même envoyé une vidéo pour motiver
les troupes
en fait ça dépend si dans le futur qu'il
a vu la vidéo pour motiver les gens fait
gagner le match il mettra la vidéo bien
sûr ah oui forcément en fait il vient il
vient il vient il vient du tueur fut
donc il sait tout en fait c'est que ça
va gagner quoi c'est super beats et
c'est le patron du game quoi c'est le
patron du game bon c'est une structure
de type française n'y a pas encore le
pion aux 6 t tu pourras faire des fous
g4 on va voir on va voir casser cette
tâche 4h 5h 6 1 pour envoyer ce label
est dans les plantes kosteniuk ça payera
fabo seaway échanges en v4 food et 2
elle veut s'en prendre aux pions b
katché pas j'aurais préféré garder un
centre moi j'aurais préféré garder une
gros chêne de pions mais c'est parce que
j'aime bien les structures type
française donc forcément ça me donne
envie
avant on va voir ce que ça donne elle
veut faire flasher 6 après et h 4 h 5 à
l'attaqué droit partie avec flash 6 côté
kosteniuk car elle fait h3 un peuple
autres mais pas forcément mauvais elle
veut jouer contre le fou ces huit fois
ci ça là le temps ça va être très fort
tu peux avoir des idées de foisches six
cavaliers h5
et quand tu prends prend à va faire des
carriers g5 et damages 7 matin par able
c'est ce qu'elle a dû vouloir tenter et
là je pensais à la sphère fouache 6
quand même elle prépare encore il faut
arrêter de préparer la non mais super
vite c'est pas moi mon cas mon cas cela
bouge mon casque le beau gosse gg aucun
rapport avec cette personne
de toute façon donc faut pas vous
parlant cette fête news dans le tchat
marrant qu'elle fasse pas faux âge 6
personne ne connaît son identité mais
faut arrêter en tennis parce que j'ai
bayer que je fatigue et trains mais il
faut arrêter à un moment donné un
évidemment on voulait me faire tilt en
disant ça à chaque fois mais c'est bye
et par ennui n'est pas bayer par par
fatigue
ces deux choses différentes ces deux
choses très différentes
y a pas vraiment beaucoup d'infos sur
sur super blitz on sait pas on n'en sait
pas grand chose
on n'en sait pas on n'en sait pas
beaucoup sur sur ce super beats en tout
cas on sait que c'est un bon buteur et
que et qui vient du futur
en fait on sait pas si les français non
non c'est pas on sait qui est qui vit
dans enfin qui à défaut du futur
potentiel où les gens ne joue qu'en
partie longue ça il avait déjà expliqué
et où les échecs sont morts en fait les
gens ne joue plus aux échecs
beaucoup de parties ont beaucoup de
tournants partie long qui durent très
longtemps inintéressant et à force de
faire de la merde partout les échecs ont
disparu donc il ya des futurs ou les
échecs n'existe plus et du coup on sait
que super beats il vient un peu pour
pour remettre les choses dans l'ordre il
ya pour prendre cette cave un qui a une
qualité c'est quand même ballot de se le
prendre c'est quand même pas de chance à
ces terribles
c'est terrible de se rendre fou prend
1,7 c'est terrible bon je sais pas tant
de jessains et que je peux attendre
quelque chose tu vas te faire mater le
spam bon c'est trois pourquoi pas
mais oui il ya des c'est ce qu'on sait
en gros
c'est ce qu'on sait de super mixte on
apprend on connaît pas son identité on
connaît pas grand chose j'en joue à quoi
j'ai fait quand le futur faudra lui
demander ce soir moi j'en sais rien je
n'en sais rien enfin c'est la presse
pour pour koné ou 1
grâce au dur quand même
c'est dur pour la calèche de moins
carrelage ses pions de moins mais tu as
un tout petit con tre jeu avec le pion
avec aucune compensation
un peu le pion c3 fabas n'en fait femme
a déjà vues superbes lis mes oreilles le
connais pas très bien
ils se connaissent pas trop quoi et j'ai
jamais vu superbus avec vlad donc on ne
sait pas quoi
ouais kf4 qu'il faut achi c'est bien
joué ça ouais chavalier prend prise d'un
prend et bouger cet accueil g7
ouais c'est bien joué la rage c'est 3f
set assez bien joué de la part de koné
roues al elle a vraiment bien joué
wes ebit rim qui veut biskri moi c'est
super beats qui est venu à moi en fait
il m'a dit très important les échecs
sont en grand danger
j'ai besoin de toi c'est bien joué ce
qu'elle a fait la food & 2 franchement
la connais roux a les mêmes yeux quoi
c'est fou tourache s'enferme la dame et
les gars tour à six ans ferme la dame
non mais c'est terrible c'est terrible
de perdre c'est avec les blancs issou
ola chants que la lâche ancla ouais
c'est terrible c'est terrible réalité
plus en plus nette
pas de chance les partis ne sont pas
fouillés bombe adam 3 o6 quoi oui
bobette à ok ça sauf peut-être un peu
près mais c'est quand même très mal pour
elle c'est quoi être foutu en fait c'est
encore pire
c'est encore pire alors retour nada
c'est terrible c'est terrible avec ayew
ne s'est pas super seulement il ya plus
et devait le faire des cadres des trois
danses et bien joué et des 3d des deux
c'est un ace et filles et ben tu prends
au nom au nom le pion par os est
terrible elle va laisser faire dame
assez terrible
ses dérives ses terres est annoncée les
blancs qui doivent en premier c'est les
gens qui vont gagner c'est terrible il
doit y avoir mathon alors il ya
peut-être un match s'il doit y avoir un
match où il est où le baht dame j'ai
vite pourquoi je fais davier 8 tempo tu
as une minute vingt cherche leva de
force et c'est reparti c'est reparti
elle va faire quoi elle va faire
fouetter fouet cette tourbe et sept rois
b crois aussi ça le monte à l'espagne
travailler et pour 17 et ses filles josh
childress pourquoi t'as pas fait vous
croire this way c'est dommage c'est
dommage c'est vrai ce que je pense je
suis fier fourcroy ferry mais en fait
pour moi je fais pas des trois là ça et
c'est long je renvoie réf
bon ça va peut-être pas si facilement
c'est rien c'est pas si facile
ce qu'ils avaient tour c'est ici c1
dames pourpre en cavalier prend et puis
on avance ou f4 échec est fou des
limites mais c'était pas si facile à
voir mais c'est pas sûr que tu gagnes en
plus mais à pascal dommage de laisser
faire dame est géniale cette partie
danse esquissés troisième est bon avec
peu de temps ce pas facile à voir
mais en fait vous prend assiste quand
même mais avec peu de temps en fait tu
regardes c'est un cahier france et 1 et
ça doit aller quoi trembler oui je
rigole
non mais c'était drôle parce qu'il y
avait quand même qualité pion de plus
après il y avait il y avait une pression
va être foutu et ça s'est retourné et
quoi c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire
faut être connecté à 20h15 elliott
mais tu risques le ban tu es bien au
courant elliott en cas de défaite du
match et des fêtes de ta part tu risques
entre un et trois jours de panne
wahou
cette partie
mais ces belles compétitions vous a
montré avec fabien il y avait le moment
marois avait couché ninacs ans a raté
trois matchs en 1 ya quand même des
partis des parties sympa la partie qu'on
a vu elle était cool quand on est bien
tombée ça on a bien commencé la journée
là je suis heureux ouais ils ont raté
trois m'attendais à des moments
différents et c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire c'était deux championnes
du monde crève
du coup on espère qu est ce qu on dit
qu'ils feraient un avantage la taille
conséquent et après que ça se bat à fond
bon là il ya une pio isolé mais la
première la première partie a vraiment
lancé les débats
offrant des cats qui a et b 3 qui menace
bkm fo prend des quatre dames prend des
4 km et 3 la menace n'est pas par et le
tas ne tient plus je reprends c'est ça
le foot français est fou prend avec
d'eux mêmes c'est terrible c'est
terrible elle n'a pas vu ça a fallu même
charcle patron l'avait vu quand même
froid des cas tv3 alors les deux l'ont
pas vu c'est raté ça s'arrache qui
promet un match qui promet alors de zéro
c'est le beau match peut-être épreuve 6
maintenant on enfouit 3 peut-être qu'il
est probable si ces deux faits
intéressants
jean-francis tour ses sets c'était
peut-être intéressant mais pas sûr que
c'était bon j'aurais peut-être joué
quand même plutôt fou ou 3
et ça lui à tony stark non mais au moins
c'est un beau match pour moi c'est un
beau match c'est mieux ça en fait que de
voir juste des partie insipide bavière
c'est déjà bien il ya déjà eu au moins
quatre trucs élémentaire raté c'est bon
quoi
clairement on va passer une bonne
journée
clairement la journée fantastique ça
démarre très ça démarre sur les chapeaux
de roue quoi mieux vous je sais pas est
ce que vraiment on doit parler du pion
isolé faible à long terme ou pas à paf
la question c'est ce cri on peut menacer
des fourchettes des trucs comme ça quoi
c'est beau quoi faire si vous voyez le
nombre de cas il faut qu'ils m'envoient
le google docs là parce que je suis un
peu en sueur pour le match de ce soir
ça y est me l'envoyer
j'en parlais développer ces pièces
jouées l'écossaise s non mais c'est
marrant parce qu'elle joue quand même
assez bien qu'onéreux les calmes de 1600
fidh
mais c'est une très bonne joueuse et
kosteniuk elle est très très forte quoi
il ya des travaux la saison n'ont
peut-être marre aussi mais après a quand
même beaucoup d'argent en jeu
il ya 3000 $ à la gagnante pour chaque
tournoi pour la gagnante du tournoi
c'est quand même pas mal pour jouer une
heure et demie quatre jours d'affilée
quoi pour six heures de boulot
donc il ya quand même une somme
intéressante en jeu et une qualification
possible pour la grande finale où il y
aura peut-être encore 5,6 me l'enjeu
quoi mais là c'était beau drap tfou
prend des quatre qui est b3d 2 c'est
quoi le castel france angers création de
chasse comme et classement classique
alors assez simple en fait du coup le
classement de chaises comme s'était
classé par rapport aux partis qui se
joue sur une chaise comme et le
classement classique été classé par
rapport aux partis toujours en classique
quoi donc ses deux deux types de parties
différentes mais il ya souvent une
chorus précités bon / tu as comme tu es
bon classique c'était mon en classique
tu es bon surtout est comme ca corrobore
way serait d'anthologie le retour de
super vite ouais ouais ça va être beau
le retour de super miss après a confirmé
quoi faut quand même qu'ils réussissent
à venir et tout mais normalement
superbus n'est jamais en retard
l'autre jour super vie cela était en
retard il est revenue dans le passé pour
pour être de nouveau à l'heure assez
joli ça t'apprend ses quatre tours 30
pour prendre dame prend fou prend tout
reprend mais je pense qu'elle va le voir
mon normalement elle devrait voir quand
même elle devrait pas faire dame france
et 4
ouais ça entonne corrobore way you dig s
par ajout à la buvette
bien joué
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs de
ski à la paire de fou et jeux sur deux
ailes du coup plus fort que lecavalier
après je sais pas comment super vite va
se débrouiller pendant le stream 1
est-ce qu'il peut revenir dans le passé
du stream et où je suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr qu'en la ville puisse pas disons
si en fait il ya forcément une réalité
temporaire trempe temporelle dans
laquelle on gagne le match ce soir mais
c'est pas sûr que ce soit la salle dans
laquelle on est quoi disons que si on
perd nous en fait c'est peut-être des
gens dans une autre temporalité qui vont
gagner quoi en fait faut espérer qu'on
soit dans la bonne temporalité il
applique ainsi on va les rajouter un peu
plus tard là il se passe rien pour le
moment sur les câbles mais je laisse un
peu les scores des deux matches au début
histoire de bien voir qui joue quoi
on s'arrête à ce qu'elle fait un peu
plus protégé v6
après on va se barrer en dolorean et on
reviendra dans le temps réel permet de
jouer ça et ça c'est nul de chez nul ya
un gros chantier l'après-midi à côté de
chez moi
mais bon comme je vous dis fait trop
chaud pour tous fermés
alors avant jouer ça ouais mais je pense
qu'elles ont raison a dit qu'elles sont
capables de perdre parfois jean-paul
front jouait pas ça en fait je comprends
pas comment perdre mais on peut dire
tout à l'heure t'as qu'à une qualité il
un pion de plus et trois quoi prêter une
dame de loin pas donc
après je t'avoue que c'est dur à gagner
mais
ça fait nul qu'à une petite petrov
à l'été fair play les raisons du choix
un peu conejo sar est bien placé ouais
et bien placé 1 s'est qualifié il n'y a
pas vraiment de placement à voir elle
nous a vraiment plu un sahara
franchement c'est fou quoi
vous êtes tellement heureux de sa race
est fou il ya un classement général des
grands prix way sharks le patron mais
elle a ses goûts nina et ou chez nina
loin devant
ah je suis en train de vous dire votre
chat sarah bien qu'assez sur le grand
prix bas un vrai moyen pour le moment on
verra faut forer qu'elle aille au moins
en finale de celui là pour avoir une
chance bon c'est une petite position
avec la petite majorité allaient droit
peut-être tu peux rêver un cahier sur
des caténaires f5 mais sûrement les
noirs ils vont te faire un f6 ou quoi
attend on va voir
on va voir
sarr est bien classé sur les grands prix
du coup c'est la même question du chat
que je revois mon elle va sûrement être
le quart ayant réussi suspense avec chez
nina et guo linna à 20 points y a plus
trop de suspense ouais faudrait vraiment
un gros résultat peut-être de kosteniuk
ou ou de sarah dans ce tournoi la cua de
carrément bessette je trouve très
bizarre mais il ya une raison pour palm
attend aussi sûrement des g4 f5 ou quoi
paraît qu'on tue peu au regard elle va
organiser ces quatre prises prise d'un
f3 et jouer sur le pion sait si c'est
pas bête un mail car elle est en baisse
est extraordinaire
dans cas
la partie continue 1 on va voir comment
ça réagit côté côté noir
damien d'un mach 4 c'est classique elle
va préparer cinq fois justice si jamais
un écho de ces luxe c'est toujours très
direct quoi c'est bien mais ce carré en
bz c'est fou quand même mais elle a dû
avoir voir un problème sur qui aura lieu
aussi ce qu'on n'a pas vu parce que
sinon ça fait pas trop sens
je sais que c'est pas mal que le vrai
m'envoyer sur le roi
ok sur cale a voulu elle a voulu passer
le fulham et ce cavalier a tellement du
mal à revivre natale en pas de case
voici ses terres il avoue prendre
apprend qu on prend pions prend
cavaliers prend et installer un fou en
d4
c'est vraiment terrible
elle est mal
très mal en pis et dans l'autre match du
coup c'est quoi le score sarika qui mène
je pense qu'à arica baguette pour marika
énorme favori de l'autre match à la c4
qui est des cats est terrible mieux car
il y ait des cadets tellement dominants
il contrôle tout quoi fou des
trois-tours f3 non ouais c'était sûr et
tourache 3
elle va mater kosteniuk c'est sûr
ce terrible
well cavaliers en bessette il va faire
perdre la partie mais c'était sur un
cantalien bessette qui verrait jamais le
jour
pour h3 et sympa condé 5 est sympa
sandra je reviendrai bon je suis là mais
je peux pas écouter à bayer les prêts
passés c'était très mauvais un mathieu
c'était très mauvais
c'est pas ailleurs ne s'est pas ailleurs
contre langnau
un nom à sarah elle joue contre joue à
une joue demain c'est sûr
c'est sûr si tu la préparait contre
contre langnau
tu t'es trompé d'adversaire
mais prévoit sont mauvaises
ça c'est sûr que les prépas seront
mauvaises c'est sûr en tout cas que ces
newco ses yeux qu'elle peut gagner ce
tournoi
je reste a pas intérêt à prendre du
cavalier filer la qualité est joué
ce que ça se fait de cannes très mal
bref 5,6 à l'air sympa où j'ai quatre
aussi il faut prendre h5
5 ça a l'air sympa
dame prend 1,5 et la finale un pion de
plus d'après tu étais tellement bien que
tu espérer mieux que les deux pions plus
mais bon
voilà réfléchir un petit peu de tours g5
si elle n'a pas joué c'est moi qui ait
bougé les pièces
lorsqu'elle joue cavalier f5 c'est bien
aussi
peut-être très fin
tours f3 défendre ça me paraît difficile
avec cinq selon la pendule en f1 après
tout est possible
ça paraît complètement fini mais bon on
n'est jamais sûr de rien qu'elle est
tombée et ce sera la fin pour cette
cadence donc aux seniors va gagné très
facilement
bon écoute et ça c'est gagné pour
kosteniuk donc ouais non la normale en
la cadence est terminée et oui fan ça
fait un an et demi un an et demi on va
peut-être aller voir le match de willy
fans alors après j'imagine que c'est la
pause par tous
là c'est trop facile nous sommes en
profiter pour prendre les caméras des
joueuses
quand on verse am à l'otan t'as pas
intérêt à jouer vite pour pas lui
laisser le temps de réfléchir
mais ça dépend mois déjà gagné pas mal
de parties quand ils en font ça
donc valide tchèque voit les rajouter
les calmes pendant la pause et donc on
va aller voir le match
wesley du côté de willy fans
donc on va mettre arica ici
la rega qui est même concentré pendant
la pause quoi et où ifan en bas
va changer les noms
quand j'arrivais avec matthew nouvelles
sur la pédagogie coachée par avec
mathieu en juillet sûrement à temps
arica c'est difficile à écrire les merci
a dit commagnac pour le raid de 27
personnes merci tonton ouais voilà
ok comme ça va repartir sur ce match là
les amis arica c'est une joueuse
indienne
donc
et c'est pas le premier tour c'est
l'écart et si c'est mal écrit
elle est super concentré la loi regarder
des trucs théorique je pense ça et elle
se barre elle se barre écoutez quand
elle veut hein
c'était bien marrant la première partie
était bien drôle
c'est la première phase du match on va
voir la phase ii/iii plus un an
ouais il fou prend des quatre athées
parler de jouer de ses charmes que les
mercis samir us et demain et après
demain sera pas moi qui se trouverait
sera femmes et andré a de nouveau j'ai
redemandé une pause quoi je re souffle
ça me fera du bien je vais souffler à
fond bref peut-être que je demanderai
superbe l'itw m
on ne reverra pas avant samedi mais
puisqu'un an vendredi sur un live
mais c'est vrai que ce soir ce sera pas
moins mais si je l'aï vu en première
partie quand même un peu avant le saut
de battles avant l'arrivée de super
blitz avant l'arrivée de super blitz
usher un petit peu là ça va bientôt
reprendre
ça va bientôt reprendre
en espérant que ça envoie du jeu et ses
petits champs rhénan riche et plus
coiffier plus quoi vous raconter en fait
c'est c'est dur qua non et c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident un nom je
commenterai pas le seul bateau
l'antonyme choix et par là ce soir
j'ai déjà dit je le redis c'est ce sera
pas moi ce soir je serai pas sur les
trois parties aucune pression on atteint
90% se calment en dessous des attentes
non c'est pas mal ça recule patrons
petits 80 56 80 c'est déjà bien
alors à compte de la situation des
femmes dans les échecs la différence du
classement est ce que j'aime bien d'un
mois de base j'aimerais bien que ce soit
mix n'appréciez pas possible d'y
commagnac c'est pas possible dans le
sens où si tu te situes fait les échecs
mix du jour au lendemain tu as tout à
aucune femme qui peut vivre des échecs
donc tu es obligé de garder les échecs
séparé fin de fer à l'e3 mixtes hommes
et les tournois femmes séparés à l'heure
actuelle
après il faudrait vraiment trouver une
solution pour pouvoir unifier ça ouais
donc un truc ce serait bien d'avoir un
plan sur le long terme sur 20 30 ou 40
ans pour pour permettre aux femmes de
rattraper les hommes et d'avoir le même
niveau donc ça ce sera un beau projet
ouais mais ça demande sa demande du
courage et c'est de lancer un projet
pareil
parce que parce qu'à l'heure actuelle en
fait c'est juste pas possible à l'heure
actuelle si tu n'y fit ou et enlève les
compétitions féminines vraiment tu t'en
lève tout les fans des échecs c'est
terrible tu peux juste pas le faire à
l'heure actuelle ça c'est juste une
réalité
après les raisons cc c'est autre chose
mais c'est une réalité une réalité non
mais c'est pas une question radius de
dire qu'elles sont plus nulle ou quoi
elle assez juste réel là on regarde des
ex championne du monde
pas un conejo et ex-numéro un mondial
écossais nuque avec championne du monde
et on voit bien que c'est moins fort que
les hommes font imagine si on met
cramique contre contre peter l'écho et
en plus il joue même plus l'écho et
chroniques sont même retraités et là on
a déjoué sont même pas retraités mais la
différence de niveau elle va être elle
va être terrible
alors on n'a pas vrai on n'a pas les
bonnes joueuses là on va prendre les
bonnes jouer ça au vert les deux parties
n'ont après on sait pas on sait pas
comment la raison pour laquelle c'est
comme ça on la connaît pas pourquoi
pourquoi elles sont moins forte mais
c'est une réalité et ça on peut pas on
peut pas aller à l'encontre donc tant
mieux qu'ils aient des compétitions
réservées aux femmes ça leur permet de
jouer des compétitions de haut niveau et
de vivre des échecs et ça permet de
développer les échecs
femme s'est inquiétée spécialement le
licencie et via les gens qui pensent
qu'il ya moins de licenciés il y en a
d'autres qui pensent que c'est social y
en a d'autres qui pensent que c'est
comme ça il ya un peu tous les avis dans
la nature mais il y a personne qui peut
te dire la raison personne ne sait c'est
pas pourquoi juste on sait pas on peut
on sait pas donc on sait pas on sait pas
mais c'est très présomptueux de donner
une raison
après faut pas exagérer ou lifan la plus
fore jose actuelle battre n importe quel
j'aime français sauf mvl bacrot laurent
frayssinet vlad quatre chefs qui a aussi
été plus fort au mieux de sa forme
enfin sauf beaucoup en fait et il ya
sûrement plus de femmes dans le monde
qui joue que deux français donc
l'argument du nombre et ça peut se tenir
en fait l'argument du nombre pour plein
de raisons
mais il se trouve que
on sait pas j'ai oublié pas qui est son
meilleur classement c'était peut-être
60e mondial je sais pas où coup 70e j'ai
dit baky mais tous les fronts c'est là
que j'ai cités ont eu un meilleur
classement
vraiment on connaît pas la raison c'est
même pas la peine de débattre on sait
pas il ya aucune étude sérieuse qui a
été fait personne ne sait
personne ne sait pourquoi c'est comme ça
et wlan avec un excellent article là
dessus d'ailleurs avec plusieurs
hypothèses
c'est l'article c'était vraiment
intéressant il y avait il y avait quatre
cinq hypothèses différentes
le nombre de joueuses faye avait plein
de plein plein de plein de possibilités
et c'était à la fin il conduit jusque il
en savait rien quoi personne ne sait et
sur ces articles étaient peut-être sur
son site web
bon c'est pas moi on peut dégager des
pistes mais rien conclure on peut on
peut pas savoir
et ça peut être un mélange de plusieurs
choses aussi ce qui est d'autant plus
difficile c'est peut-être pas que il
enfin l'adil avait détaché 4 5 choses
différentes ça peut être un mélange des
quatre cinq facteurs mais du coup
clairement c'est plutôt bien qu'ils
essaient compétition réservée aux femmes
et judith paga la fetaf disway alafé top
10 mondial
ouais c'est bien joué qu'à l'étranger
cette frange et 7 kg et des 6 et le
cavalier h6 tombe tard autre relate
l'article non mais après moi je pense
qu'il faudrait plutôt encouragé à faire
que des tournois mixtes
parce que je pense que quand tu cantonne
les joueurs dans un dans un domaine
moins concurrentiels en fait ils se
tirent moins vers le haut t'aurais un
peu la même chose avec les échecs russe
et d'échecs français genre les rues sont
beaucoup plus forts aux échecs que les
français bon il ya une question d'école
des échecs mais aussi une question quand
réussi à moins de 2006 tu es nul mais
vraiment nul en fait c'est tu n'existes
pas en fait à moins de 1600 donc le fait
qu'il n'existe pas à moins de 2600 ça te
pousse est plus fort et encore plus loin
que ça a moins de 2720 tu restes comme
un peu une merde tu vas pas être en
équipe nationale tu vas rien faire en
fait faux ok en russie pour être sérieux
faut au moins 27 40 ou 27,50 si tu veux
vraiment être quelqu'un pris au sérieux
et du fait que 2006 soit l'équivalent on
va dire de 24,50 en france et que 27 50
en russie c'est l'équivalent de 26 80 en
france
en disant ça comme ça bah du coup
en fait ça tire tout le monde vers le
haut parce que une fois que tu arrives à
2006 en fait tu vas tu commence à peine
à exister face citepa 2006 à 25 ans
c'est ridicule donc du coup en fait
ça tire tout le monde vers le haut mais
donc les russes sont aussi c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles ils sont plus
forts donc je pense que ça joue
largement et peut-être que les échecs
féminin c'est pour être au top niveau il
fallait 2800 et que tu jouais toujours
contre des hommes et que dans enfin en
mixte que tu toujours en mx et pour
gagner en mx fallait être beaucoup plus
fort en fait ça te tire vers le haut et
non à titre personnel je pense que ça ça
ça joue déjà beaucoup en vrai au delà du
fait qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'hommes qui
joue etc qui rajoute encore une
différence bien entendu parce que
évidemment si tu as dix fois plus
d'hommes qui joue à dix fois plus de
chances d'avoir des gars au niveau c'est
normal
jacques louvion glisse ça tire vers le
haut mais ça peut aussi découragés oui
mais autant que ça peut dès qu'un
décourager les garçons ça décourage
autant les garçons que les filles
c'est justement ce truc social charpy le
patron à force de se dire oui les filles
si elles ont une des adversaires trop
forts ça les décourage elles vont
arrêter
en fait tu l'aimé déjà en situation
d'être moins forte donc quelque part
inconsciemment tu les pousse déjà être
moins forte en fait tu les conditionnent
avec moins forte
oui si tu as trop de compétition tu vas
arrêter mais je te mets des adversaires
faciles pour être bien sûr que tu
viennes des parties ben quelque part
c'est c'est quand même un message assez
négatif que tu envoies dès le début en
fait qui te pousse peut-être être moins
fort bon du coup je pense que c'est
plutôt là dedans à jeu mais c'est un
avis comment dire j'ai pas fait face et
il n'y a pas d'étude ya pas de recherche
ou quoi c'est un ressenti
il faudrait qu roberts-- corpore sa part
dont avec avec des études clair et net
fait qu'ils confirment ou infirment
willy fans qui a une bonne technique en
finale
bien joué ou ifan mais bon ça c'est mon
avis personnel après
c'est mon avis personnel et à ça veut
pas du tout dire que j'ai raison
enfin de façon la seule solution il faut
réussir à le vérifier ses 2,7 pouces et
le truc à être mixtes au le plus
possible
mais évidemment si on fait ça ça pose un
gros problème à toutes les joueuses pros
actuellement tu aurais beaucoup de mal à
vivre des échecs et c'est dur quoi c'est
un genre de génération sacrifiée quoi et
peut-être même pour rien ce qui est
terrible
vous savez quoi pour y arriver
rapidement travailler ce qu'on veut
faire les deux mixtes et féminins à elle
en fait quand tu fais mixte et féminin
tu comptes tonnes quand même pas mal au
féminin parce que les tournants
importants ils vont être féminin
championnats du monde ce sera féminin et
les tournois où tu as beaucoup d'argent
ils seront féminin donc pour réussir tu
vas tu vas quand même un peu cantonné au
féminin mais après c'est bien pour les
jouets ce qu'ils sont pro actuellement
parce que si tu changes le système du
jour au lendemain tu mets plein de
femmes dans le problème et ça c'est pas
bien
c'est un système de l'undd finalement 1
dans la structure est ce qu il fallait
une chance contre amv elles n'ont donc
une les trois miss avec des prix pour
les meilleures femmes du fantôme yade
ouais mais le truc c'est que tu envoies
quand même un message depuis le début de
la carrière d'une d'une jeune fille en
lui disant pour réussir à bien vis des
échecs faut que tu arrives à 2500 et si
tu arrives à 2500 c'est bon tu es très
très forte
et tu auras des prix est toujours allé
tourner et c'est alors que site envoie
un message en disant pour pouvoir
exister dans ce milieu foued 27,50
peut-être on n'aurait plus ce qui
arriverait jusqu'à 27 56 ans est rien je
sais pas en fait
c'est des trucs à serait d'être des
choses à tester mais sur le long terme
près le tc sur 20 ans 30 ans et tirer
des conclusions que après ça pourrait
passer c'est sur un an ou deux ans a été
championne du monde à 26 et atteint son
objectif chaput a progressé c'est ça et
tu te places comme objectif d'être 2006
et déjà déjà dans les catégories jeunes
aussi c'est comme ça
le gap comment ça se passe créé à partir
de quel âge pareil je pense dé 8,9 en
fait fin dès le début en fait t'as un
gap tout de suite reste je sais pas
exactement mais regarde les plus jeunes
grands maîtres de l'histoire etc
c'est quasiment que des garçons t'as que
pôle gare en fait qui est un ovni mais
sinon c'est que des gars on regarde tous
les jeunes qui sont très doués fille
ruth chanial sarine prague anand abdou
sato rohff sinndar of mao rizzi materia
poursuites et des français c'est que des
garçons
donc l'écart avec les plus forts se fait
très très tôt
dd tout petit en fait mais là encore ça
peut venir de la manière d'entraîner ça
peut venir des objectifs fixés ça ça
peut y avoir plein de raisons sociales à
sa part al le pion celle ci soit mais le
fou il va revivre via un 8 h 5
céret en fait le fou il revit et c'est
juste complètement égal là je serai dans
f 4 je ferais nul avec le grand temps
bien
on va faire à 5 g 6 et ça a fait un nul
attends tu peux pas t'en tfo et huit
souffrent g6 ouais mais ça c'est
dangereux
tu as tu tentes b4 qui on prend roi
monte fawcett roi monte genre mais ils
font 8 tu es le roi en b3 moi je
tenterai ça mais bon peut-être elle te
prends pas elle te fais juste ça mais
j'irai tenter ça perso par principe qui
assiste quand même pour blinder caisse
pas si con roi des trois réfugiés 5 x 4
bien jouer droit c3m est à fossettes le
retour
tu pourras pas gagné ça malheureusement
ouais matériel joue bien mais bon et du
cou du coup il peut avoir plein de
raisons différentes et puis voilà on
n'en sait rien en fait pour ce truc de
femmes et d'hommes mais je pense qu'il
faut avoir l'humilité de dire qu'on sait
pas et pas envoyer des raisons entre
guillemets stupide dans les chat ou je
ne sais pas où personne ne sait
elle joue à fond mais c'est vraiment un
gagnable ça pour l'une ou pour l'autre
égalité matérielle allez ça fait nul
barrick a un peu déçu auquel s'accroche
à ricains s'affaire une pirc moderne
des 6 et 6
madame d2 ça joue tranquille ça valait
attaquer l'europe mais peut-être le
cavalier peut rester en g8 pour protéger
la case h 6
ces chorales exa différence entre pire
qui est moderne eh ben j'ai jamais
vraiment su tenir son rang est killer je
n'arrive pas vraiment à comprendre à
quel moment une pierrick devient moderne
une moderne devient pire qui c'est un
truc qui m'a toujours dépassé dans
l'appellation et l'emporter rage qui
n'est pas la partie se bat contre ou
yifan avec le joli match à une partie
que je connais mes proches j'ai arrêté
la compétition puisque j'aime pas je
sais pas comment la pierre froide mandat
fava également une pique mais la moderne
c'est ce qu'elle a fait des 6 et 6 du
coup c'est devenu une moderne à la
famille le pion aux cinq des six cas ici
j'ai cité moderne qui retarde tf6 pour
être plus souple
ouais ok ça allait le carillon f6 tu
vois ça se ressemble tellement après
maintenant je suis pas du tout ap deux
sens j'aurais peut-être plutôt tab 2000
tony stark sais pas exactement
il ya plein de gens qui sont chauds il
ya trop de gens qui sont forts il ya
trop de gens qui sont forts
j'ai eu 2 auquel va être changée en 2000
mondiale quand même c'est pas exactement
peut-être 3000 et 4000 gens ça aussi
j'ai arrêté très tôt donc c'est dur
c'est dur de dire et sur internet en
blitz peut-être top500 je sais pas je
sais pas exactement mais peut-être
top500 sur 5 sur ciao comme 176 13 watts
et ça c'est bien ce que je pensais
enstream ans
bon position symétrique je rappelle qu'à
arica avait bien joué se pose sur
l'acompte marie ce bague
donc sans stream et j'arriverai
peut-être à 2800 plus facilement sur
czech comme mais pas plus je crois que
le mieux que j'ai fait sur czech comme
ce étape de 190 ou top 280 mais ça a
plus de valeur maintenant avec le
confinement parce que tu as plein de
grands maîtres qui joue plus beaucoup
plus sérieusement qu'avant
du coup si tu joues plus tu perds ton et
le non pas du tout why car oui les
forêts même en stream ans il est très
fort après faut dire qu'à son niveau il
ya peu de gens qui travaillent vraiment
hard en face genre maximy trahi par
d'alors qui pourrait le battre et magnus
i try part du tout n'est peut non pas un
dépôt il joue mais il trahi par ddt
fo prend 5 peut-être ici
on va voir ses katas pour les noirs ses
katas pour harry caine dans l'autre
match c'est quoi le score il ya déjà 4 0
et sa santé que c'est nous qui était
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup plus forte
wake à rousset dur à juger parce qu'à
son niveau en fait c'est un peu
différent mais bon on est pauvre il a
essayé de faire 3003 il réussit pas donc
je sais pas il est vraiment fort écart
ou en 2d
voilà faut faire gaffe parce que surtout
reprendre même et on pouvait cette fois
juste pas si grave fait roi prend et
échanges
c'est terrible
ça va faire 4 2 l'écart va se creuser là
en faveur du oui fans on va faire un
petit tour b si cela elle va raser
encore un pion et elle va aller gagner
sa tranquille
j'imagine bien tous prendront eux 5 et
ferb et 4.6 faut réussir
ouais c'est fini c'est pion à passer et
là tu reviens en c6 et envoie le pion 1
qu'elle a tué tour ses six tours prend
1,5 et en france et 4s est simple la
wepad à fond ainsi tu arrives à 2005 et
que tu arrêtes tu reprends un sac en
sera toujours 2005 mais tu vas pas être
2005 en fait ça qu'il faut que tu
comprennes
de toute façon
elle va revenir avec la tour et tours 3
ce trailer ouais ça fait 4 2 le score se
creuse en faveur du oui fans elle est
vraiment plus forte un talent joue bien
bon c'est une petite française
bon du coup le truc c'est que l'écart
est le cavalier à eux deux il est pas
mal placé puisqu'il protège le pion des
quatre donc c'est pas mal et les noirs
ils vont essayer d'aller l'attaqué avec
dan b6 éventuellement ou faux c'est tf6
pour casser la tête de la structure de
pions c'est les deux plans classique
soit sans prendre à des 4,60 prendra de
elle s'en prend à des quatre c'est pas
mal
ils échangent karelia 5
elle veut jouer pour cavaliers b3 ou
cavaliers ses 4 encaissés trois noms
donnés star que les parties elles sont
assez intéressantes le truc c'est que le
le souci en fait de ces parties là c'est
sais pas c'est pas vraiment ça c'est que
comme c'est sur le même tournoi en fait
ça perd complètement de son intérêt
c'est intéressant de regarder des
tournois mais faut que faut que les
tournois et des formats attrayant moi je
sais pas trop elle file le pion look ne
prend pas
y a pas d'âme ces trois là qui gagnent
juste tout de suite ah non le ses
protégés à millas a attaqué aussi où là
je vois plus rien mesdames c3 sa part s
est formé adam prend des quatre là oui
c'est assez terrible pour c'est terrible
ça pour pourra rica et sur cavaliers f3
le retour elle va refaire dame ses trois
échecs et ses terribles
ces tarifs varient car en sueur et bien
non car elle y prend 1,5
je sais pas lequel des deux mais lâche
les deux pions centraux sur dame prend
f4 le problème c'est qu'à calais france
et 4 contres découverte
ils m'ont répondu quoi comme jeu proposé
le système de ça ça leur plaît pas en
fait le système de cette yanis je sais
pas trop pourquoi mais ça ils préfèrent
ce système là sont pas fan du système
set ça doit être un système plus à
l'européenne
bon là jusqu'à vallée prend et cavaliers
5 je dirais reprend d'ici et food & cie
serait peut-être fou des six direct bon
il ya une petite chance pour harry caps
caf ou b2 est fou prend g7 qui arrive ce
pas si simple un jeune qu'on sait déjà
qu'à 13 ans et qui joue pas
régulièrement il deviendra un calage
2003 mais ça dépend de ton talent pâte à
pain peut-être jamais peut-être jamais
tu dépasses 16 cents en fait on n'en
sait rien mais dit wak 2003 sait rien en
fait
là il n'y a pas un fou prend b5 sympa
mais c'est quand même trois pions un
bond après un blitz ça peut se jouer
non c'est pas mais en fait tu dis toi
que ton objectif c'est un garçon et que
tu veux faire quelque chose dans les
échecs c'est au moins 2700 donc on va
dire 2006 50 donc de toute façon que tu
arrives à 2003 ou pas en fait ça change
rien je t'en fout en fait tu joues pour
t'amuser
si tu arrives à monter à 2003 tant mieux
mais ton objectif faut être plus 26 50
27 même en forme et partout en fait ça
doit être un objectif mais bon deux mini
3 c'est pas si facile que ça et si tu
travailles 4 5 heures par jour tous les
jours tu dois y arriver j'assume et 15
heures par semaine tu devrais y arriver
si tu te regarde c'est possible oui bah
oui vas tu peux en fait mais c'est pas
si facile
ce que tu peux faire d'alger 6 es fou
aux 7 et rock
cleese et 2003 en france qu à 2007 non
j'ai dit 2006 qui vaut à 2007
mais cette partie n est pas si simple en
fait ce que t'as pas grand retour à tour
saint lary qu'à la tête retournée près
c'est chaud et pas retourner dans le
sens mieux mais retourner dans le sens
c'est 50 50 c'est 2006 en russie qui
fait 2007 en france
non c'est 2007 en russie fait 2600
française ça
même si ça a l'air de vraiment mettre
fin aux espoirs blanc est d'avis que je
proposais ça avait l'air bien mais
peut-être une problème un problème avec
un dame b 5 échecs
j'ai peut-être raté un truc mais là
c'est pas mal ce qu'elle fait ou ifan
pour les blancs faut absolument
s'activer sur la colonne c'est pour
essayer de rentrer
ouais là c'est pareil ce que tu fais
tout reprend b cette ut active ce que tu
veux avec les blancs là c'est réussir à
rentrer sur la colonne c'est pour
réussir à attaquer le roi des deux côtés
en fait ça ces positions que je joue
bien généralement avec les blancs puis
hyper dangereux dans ces trucs là pour
ça que je joue bien les français je me
sens super bien un truc c'est très bien
joué ça de la part de huy fans de contre
attaquer sur f2 donc l affaire tour
besset tête à la chance sur roy c6
d'avoir ton c7 ici courbet 1
elle va se cacher entre 6 et c'est extra
c'est bien très bien jouer cette partie
à merouana saint seiya il ya fougue et 8
ici mais ça j'avais l'ordi il y avait
foule et 8 et c'était fini parce que
surtout reprendre les huit y avait
d'am-dam ici or il a fallu faire touré
fins olala c'est terrible c'est terrible
parce que parce que sa paire mais elle a
raté mais ça c'est parce que j'avais
leur dis que j'ai vu mais le fou les
huit échecs suroît 8 y avait tout
racisme at et surtout reprend et
mesdames troisième set très difficile à
voir aller c'était dur à voir mais elle
avait quasiment retourné à rica c'est
dommage
bon ça fait 5 2 donc match quasiment
terminée de l'autre côté ça fait 6 0
donc un peu comme il ya en fait un des
matches ce que c'était plaisant à suivre
la rga qui joue pour le juste pour le
fun et 1600 c'est donc pas trop mal mais
un peu décevant ne s'est pas mal enfin
1600 c'est beau un bel élan il ya peu de
gens qui arrivent mais dis toi bien que
juste mois pour arriver à mon niveau
j'ai passé dix ans à faire du try hard
pas je me faisais la réflexion l'autre
soir je me disais quand je me dis que
les gens qui ont à ce qu'ils jouent bien
à trackmania c'est ouf leur niveau en
fait ils ont beaucoup moins try hard le
jeu que moi les échecs c'est un jeu qui
est très difficile c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que tous les jeux vidéo que tu
peux voir
c'est terrible c'est un jeu très dur il
faut énormément travaillé il ya
énormément de choses à savoir
c'est énormément énormément énormément
de travail et mon vélo en réel c'est
2003 mais je vois plutôt joué à 2004 on
va dire parce que j'ai arrêté vraiment
loin de mon niveau et l'eau et quand
j'ai repris jouer mieux que ce et lola
aussi donc ok j'ai dû jouer à 2004 2004
50 pas plus pas moins
pas plus d'être deux mille fois et on y
revint 2004 aller et j'avais un coach
tout seul dit non j'ai un coach
ouais moi je gagne ma vie grâce au
streaming carrément mais pour gagner sa
vie aux échecs il faut plutôt être 26 50
27 en tant que joueur pro si t'es pas au
moins deux mille six cent cinquante tu
vas pas gagner ta vie
eh bien il va et dit qu'il valait 1 2450
2005 en vite ce minimum
wayne bridge ou opus bien sûr c'est
évident mais si je me forçais un peu
apprendre masse de théorie a beaucoup
travaillé ouais mais bon
c'est pas assez
c'est trop faible 25 c'est trop faible
faut plutôt 26 50 27 et ça c'est dur à
24,50 sur celui où tu peux survivre si
des clubs de paix pour les parties de
référence et enfin tu galères à moins de
2006 tu galères tu galères en 2006 c'est
vraiment le hello que tu dois viser pour
avoir un petit peu quelque chose à 2004
cinq en 2005 qui devient prof web 25,50
aussi c'est à partir de 26 que tu peux
commencer à vouloir avoir un semblant de
carrière pro
bon donc alexandra kosteniuk le match
est gagné où il fan aussi quasiment donc
à moins une surprise là dans les bulles
est née c'est sympa de voir où il
fallait réussir ça me fasse plaisir à
titre personnel je connais le
déplacement des pièces c'est tout ça me
donne combien dé l'eau dce s'adonnent
déjà 300 400 1 er dragon c'est déjà
quelque chose de connaître le
déplacement des pièces
tu sais déjà faire quelque chose tu es
là quoi mais bon devenir pro dans
n'importe quel jeu ou sport c'est dur
hein les gars faut pas croire s'est pas
ouvert à tout le monde
wu yi fan mais je crois qu'à la
finissent en forêt
je crois que c'est standford tue pas sur
quel plaisir et prouve que tu as joué
avec des gens beaucoup plus faible en
lots a aucun aucun oui fanal qi d'échec
et grandes études c'est un ovni aussi
ouais bien sûr elle est incroyable cette
femme à l'extraordinaire très clairement
à la privilégier ses études un singe
choix respectable
est ce que ce souci d'atteindre deux
mille lots son coach oui c'est possible
oui ça explique aussi pourquoi ou des
fans est moins forte que certains hommes
je suis d'accord avec chelsea en est
qu'il aura le fait qu'elle calais dédié
moins de temps aux échecs ça joue aussi
mais ça c'est une des choses que vous la
décrivez dans un de ses articles
c'est que les hommes ont plus il ya plus
d'hommes qui sont capables de d2 voué
leur vie à une seule chose en fait que
les femmes
il a dit parler de ça dans son article
que c'était un travail en traits de
caractères plus masculin que féminin
vlad parler de sa taille reprenez des
études en disant qu'il y avait plus
d'hommes qui développer des jeux passion
qu'on vous appelle ça des syndromes
comme l'autisme moi je fasse appel à un
syndrome ou comment s'appellent
exactement mais qui avait plus d'hommes
qui développe et se ce genre de passions
plus à une pathologie pas comment
comment quel mot employer mais assez
beaucoup plus des pathologies on va dire
ce mot là
qui se retrouve beaucoup plus chez les
hommes que chez les femmes et que ça
pouvait jouer ouais syndrome du spectre
autistique qui se retrouve beaucoup plus
chez les hommes que chez les femmes et
que ça pouvait jouer en faveur des
hommes pour leur niveau échec c'est
intéressant
quelque part
et vlà lui pensait que que ça pouvait
être un des facteurs importants
donc quelque part c'est ça c'était le
point du final de glace c'est ce que lui
pensait mais évidemment c'est pas
prouvée mais il disait que c'était
fallait chercher dans cette direction
parce que c'est vrai que ça aide en fait
de s'intéresser qu'à une seule chose
dans sa vie de penser qu'à une seule
chose matin midi et soir
regardez fischer qui est devenu super
fort hills et que des échecs dès l'âge
de 12 13 ans il était tout le temps
assis devant un échiquier
il faisait absolument que ça et c'est ce
qui peut faire la différence entre une
pole de gars qui arrivé 8e mondiale mais
qui faisaient qu'un peu que ça aussi
mais julien en gros ça peut faire la
différence entre n'importe qui qui
arrivent a eu dans le top 30 mondial est
un mec qui arrive numéro 1 de penser
qu'à ça matin midi et soir continue
quand ils se lèvent quand il va se
coucher quand il mange ça aide pour être
fort aux échecs donc très clairement ça
peut être une piste quoi ça peut être
une piste après c'est une piste parmi
d'autres c'est pour ça que il ya
plusieurs facteurs en fait il peut être
combinés explique la différence de
niveau
récent intéressant mais effectivement
pour n'importe qui qui est dans le chat
ou quoi si vous commencez à dédier votre
vie aux échecs que vous faites 14h
d'échec par jour
à n'importe quel âge même savez si les
plus âgées même s'il savait que 18 20
ans vous allez devenir très fort en fait
c'est vous pensez et chaque matin midi
et soir vous ne faites que ça vous ne
sortait plus de chez vous et je vous
assure que vous allez à obtenir un bon
niveau c'est évident c'est évident donc
est-ce que sk rica va réussir à aller
chercher des points pour hk tour g4 ça
va arriver on va attaquer le pion g7 moi
j'aime bien les blancs oui les fans donc
avec une partie nulle à cazilhac fin à
99.999 de gagner le match avec une
victoire c'est 100% donc à rica qui a
pas le droit de pas le droit de laisser
passer un demi point et moi il ce moule
non je n'étais pas comme ça moi j'ai
jamais assez aimée assez les échecs pour
pour y passer pour y dédier toute ma vie
nan c'est un de mes gros point faible
d'ailleurs un de mes points faibles
c'est que j'aimais bien j'ai beaucoup
bossé ou quoi forcément puisque pour
arriver à un bon niveau il faut le faire
mais je n'étais pas prêt à donner toute
ma vie pour les échecs il ya plein
d'autres choses qui m'intéressent
vous avez pu le remarquer avec les
stream par ya plein de choses qui
m'intéressent dans la vie en vrai et du
coup j'aurais pour moi c'était
impensable en fait de faire absolument
que ça toute ma vie et c'est un énorme
point faible en fait c'est un énorme
point faible qu'avant que j'aime bien ce
tri mais j'aime bien discuter jamais un
fan j'ai fait plein de choses et à bon
là où il fan qui va remporter le match
les amis je pense parce que ce cas
fouache cinq noms annoncés dame preuve
soro iv la finale est bien f4 qui va
arriver à attention de cavaler et s'est
pas fait encore toi charest ou la contre
jeu incroyable cavaliers en bessette qui
était complètement aller elle va aller
prendre le pion à 7 c'est logique mais
ok g4 g5 c'est très très chaud là bas on
comme partie g5 qui va arriver après la
partie va être longue à ça veut dire que
harry caroit f4 elle a même pas le droit
la nulle la c3 elle veut cavaliers
detroit échec non g6 qui a aidé trois
fff 7 qui a aidé trois échecs faut
tenter elle veut pas tenter le cadet des
trois n'a pas vu qu'ils avaient des 3
c'était marrant comme coup elle mais là
j'ai huit dames et c'en est fini ou ifan
les années quatre points d'écart au
maximum y aura encore trois parties les
matchs sont terminés la déjà c'est fini
bravo ifan c'est sympa on va remettre
les scores des matchs donc il ya
toujours six points d'écart
donc ces films maggio kosteniuk et le
match du wifaq qui est terminée aussi
donc là ça va jouer mais voilà c'est
parti qui servent absolument à rien les
deux matchs sont terminés
bah non c'est un énorme point faible
cyril of de ne pas vouloir faire que ça
et de vouloir faire d'autres choses way
d'avoir beaucoup d'autres centres
d'intérêts mais bon c'est tant mieux
fausto revenus ou tant pis mais pour
faire pour pour être au top niveau c'est
un point faible
évidemment jean valade enfin vous avez
un peu vu dans les dents les master
classes quand la discute vous sentez que
de l'âge de 12 ans ou 13 ans à l'âge de
22 23 ans il a fait que des échecs
pareil quand il raconté l'anecdote qu'il
a failli se faire renverser plusieurs
fois par par des voitures parce qu'ils
lisaient des magazines des chèques pas
l'inversé
tu vois c'est il ya aussi des raisons
pour lesquelles il est vraiment fort et
ne pas ne pas être comme ça c'est un
énorme
c'est un énorme point faible c'est un
énorme point faible pour être bon pour
être très très bon aux échecs c'est un
énorme point faible enfin en tout cas si
t'as pas un talent extraordinaire mais
même comme ça il n'est pas arrivé au
premier premier plan mondial ouais bon
il est quand même un niveau deux fois
mais c'est intéressant en fait faut les
deux fois être extrêmement douées faire
absolument que ça pour être vraiment
dans les dents les meilleurs donc sa
demande ses deux grosses choses là et
c'est vrai que si t'as pas cette
capacité de travail et cette passion
face même pas une capacité de travail si
t'as pas une passion suffisante pour
être capables de faire que ça ce que je
pense pas que tu puisses autant
travaillé un truc si t'as pas une
passion de fou
kaba en moi je vois j'adore stream est
vraiment c'est quelque chose qui me
plaît beaucoup
honnêtement je pense qu'une personne qui
est pas hyper passionné par le stream
elle est incapable de faire autant
d'heures de stream et en autant d'heures
de travail que ce que j'ai fait depuis
dix ans impossible en fait c'est juste
pas possible ce que j'ai pas assez d si
on prend le streaming comme du travail
en fait j'ai dû passer les neuf
dernières années à faire des semaines je
pense à minimum 50 heures entre quand je
faisais pas que du stream et que je vais
travailler à côté avec les cours ou quoi
je pense c'est rare les semaines où j'ai
fait moins de 50 heures de travail je
suis en forme allemand si tu cumules
savez toutes les scènes entre 50 et 70
heures pendant avec deux trois semaines
de vacances dans l'année enfin tu as est
impossible de faire ça pendant pendant
sept huit neuf ans si c'est pas ta
passion moi je le prends pas comme du
travail donc c'est très facile mais si
tu prends ça comme du travail
est ce que quelqu'un peut travailler on
va dire 60 heures par semaine ce 49
semaines par par an c'est quasiment
impossible en fait fatah très peu de
gens qui sont capables d'autant travail
et surtout efficacement donc et c'est la
même chose pour les échecs en fait
c'était pas passionné de ouf tu pourras
pas travailler autant parce que je me
répète pour les gens qui sont vraiment
passionnés c'est pas vraiment du travail
en fait tisanes et c'est tant mieux mais
si t'as pas cette cette passion
incroyable pour être capables de faire
que ça tout le temps ça ça te bloque
beaucoup
ça te bloque beaucoup je pense c'est ça
on dort beaucoup de mille dominos tient
bon la partie qui dure qui va de nouveau
être gagné par willy fans allaient voir
oui fans qui s'envolent complètement
dans ce match sera car le stream
aujourd'hui je sais pas exactement à
coeur ça commence le match commence à
20h45 super blitz arrive vers 20h15
est-ce que je sors avec super bis ou pas
je sais pas encore je suis pas encore
décidée non c'est plutôt lui qui
commente quand il vient souvent je
laisse un peu stream
on verra ce rire avec lui est peut-être
peut-être tué les gens discutera avec
lui on discuterait avec super blitz et
je verrai 6 juin
pour ça que j'arrive taquine son
identité tu bosses et en cuisine zoug
c'est hyper dur ça comme métier cuistos
un métier de ouf
faut vraiment être passionné de ouf pour
faire ce métier mais c'est un beau
métier très beau métier
mais oui oui c'est des choses voilà les
échecs faut aussi être passionné comme
ça je sais pas comment on est parti sur
ce sujet a oui parce qu'on parlait du
fait que les armes avaient plus de
syndrome autiste de de syndrome du
spectre autistique je pense qu on a
appelé ça comme ça et que du coup
c'était ça doit être un avantage pour
devenir un bon joueur d'échecs fang
stand et à la théorie que vlad pensée la
plus juste
goulding situe à être passionné passé à
cannes me faire la cuisine pour faire la
cuisine à des gens qui connaissent je
suis chaud mon papa est un excellent
cuisinier
j'ai vraiment bien la cuisine mon père
il a un style de ouf
mon père cuisine très très bien a mis
les [ __ ] aussi alors forcément on en
rediscute en août mais je travaillais
pour michel rostang ah ouais t'as vu ce
qu'il soit paribas écoute après le après
la deuxième vague
peut-être
ça va gagner pour les blancs et s'arrête
une nouvelle victoire pour yifan dans ce
match finalement chiappa qui n'a pas
atteint des sommets d'intérêt c'est un
peu comme hier un dur un difficile
difficile tu regardes tranquille un
allez c'est pas mal ce qu'elle a fait
mais là un petit coup de dams et 3 pour
revenir avec les grandes jambes qui
avaient lieu deux dames 3 adam g 1
peut-être car il y ait des quatre le
retour à c'est pas mal elle récupère la
dame a laissé bien jouer les grandes
jambes n'auront pas suffi allez
peut-être elles vont faire un nul parce
qu'il ya ça joue plus pour grand chose
quel est le club mieux placé entre nice
ou cannes
as tu poses de ces questions pas ta foi
je pose des questions de ouf à chaque
fois tapez adams et 3 marche pas elle va
elle va monter le roi est roi leucatois
loi gagner avec les noirs elle a envoyé
des elle va récupérer les pions dans les
matchs en train de s'arrêter les
joueuses qui partent
allez comme ça ça à faire 7 3
et ça va s'arrêter là dessus donc j'ai
envie de dire deux matches pas très
palpitant mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
là la f1 c'est la life 9 de l'autre côté
mais le match s'est arrêté à neuf de
l'autre côté ça à partir avec les autres
matches on va les suivre sahara écoutez
on serait su à la paix pouzin
aujourd'hui place de toute façon j'ai
envie de dire
de toute façon il n'y a rien de rien
d'incroyable
d'accord la compétition 10 riz avec les
abonnés henry life bas j'espère qu'on
pourra faire ça mais là tu vois il ya
quelques petits projets que j'avais dans
ce sens là qui sont qui passe un peu à
la trappe ainsi si je puis me permettre
le peuple open vitrine qui serait cool à
organiser mais vous allez encore être
team sahara
mais c'est pas évident au vu de la
situation sanitaire
surtout que la dernière mansart parle un
peu de seconde vague de re confinement
tutti quanti quoi la pizza ananas à
méritein banda fouet très clairement
vous avez bien jouent aussi t on va voir
un
non pizza hawaiian ça peut mériter un
ban au ban des fins très très très très
clairement les amis c'est pas pour être
méchant mais à la pizza ses faveurs on
ne met pas d'ananas sur une pizza fajjar
faut être sérieux ou non mon visage
chèvre au miel
non mais case la glace et gère ça
devient diabolique au bout d'un moment
genre le diable s'est incarné dans ce
chat
t'as pas le droit de parler d'une pizza
chèvre miel fager au bout d'un moment
non mais je leur faut arrêter de dire
des choses graves comme ça sur ce chat
pizza chèvre miel
[ __ ] c'est c'est le combo quoi
pizzas kebabs j'ai déjà vu ça des pizzas
kebabs c'est terrible à pizzas kebabs
tu peux pas t'as pas le droit de faire
ça bon alors ça
sarah sadate à la semaine dernière son
bon tournoi elle est arrivée en demi
finale attend coco voix s'il ya des
recettes de pizzas aux kiwis l'harmattan
pizza aux kiwis
j'ai déjà essayé les pizzas vegan j'ai
déjà goûté les pizzas vegan déjà le fixe
à aller très très loin mais pizza pizza
pizza qui oui c'est terrible
pas mal de sujets c'est terrible ben tu
peux pas faire de la pizza aux kiwis
quoi faut être sérieux au bout d'un
moment et c'est kiwi quoi kirikou wiki
oui mais ça c'est comme une fois je suis
dans un hôtel je vous le jure je vais
dans un hôtel j'étais juste en vacances
en suisse mon peu importe a fâché par m
en vacances je vais allant je vais aller
à genève ce que j'avais pris un boulot à
genève et du coup les premiers jours le
temps de le temps de trouver un appart
je sens un hôtel j'arrive le matin au
petit déj fromage avait dû babybel non
mais je suis pas contre le baby beel
géré je veux bien que ça existe mais tu
peux pas me mettre du baby beel face
n'est pas possible en fait fléchir faut
être sérieux tu peux pas mettre du baby
beel c'est pas possible en fait tu
entends fromage
là mais j'étais choqué quoi
non mais c'est si terrible fait ma
famille est très bon comme fromage glacé
sur l avait jamais habite en france
encore à cette époque là et du cou et du
coup le baby beel était passé mais j'ai
en moi j'étais choqué tant choqué quand
on sert du baby beel ma femme ne
concerne pas d'autre match com afin que
la vache qui rit je déprime dit daalder
bas divorce un gros godillots or c'est
franchement t'as pas le choix
pas vivre avec quelqu'un qui mange de la
vache qui rit quoi ciao tony stark
on revient aux échecs dis pas tu as faim
à ben écoute revient aux échecs si tu
veux un bon alors la structure de
pioncer quoi la lega
ce cas les gens qui reconnaissent la
structure d'options ou pas à tarbes bad
enfin on va faire b5 d'anne decis ajoute
qu'elle commencerait b d'imbéciles
joueur est jouable aux siens pour jouer
l'option b 2 la tête à 5 à 4 du coup mes
bons à cinq il ya quatre peut-être ses
shows s'échangeant des 6 et on joue fou
des trois ou à quatre pour faire à 5,6
lecavalier se barre comme ça elle pourra
lancer 5 spare à jouer la jouanne joue
super bien ses positions
moi j'aime bien le jeu de jouer john je
trouve que c'est une super joueuse je
trouve qu'elle joue vraiment très bien
j'apprécie énormément son son jeu
wen jun zhu jun mais qui sait je pense
et joue son prénom qui c'est cadré de
très très près mais je pense que si les
joueuses chinoises n'avaient pas de lag
depuis le début du tournoi et qu'elle
est elle était hyper entraînés sur
internet
je pense franchement que c'est les deux
joueuses les plus fortes un sens sans
vouloir faire insulte aux autres ou quoi
mais je les trouve vraiment très fort
ces deux joueuses chinoises
j'aime beaucoup leur jeu mais la sara sa
date elle joue pas mal hein cgl cas tout
en impression de tes chansons qu'elle a
aucune aucune évolution son visage ans
quand elle joue sarah salat et à l'air
très tranquille en six mois je peux être
calé passe y avait le pion b4 elle
pourrait faire caler ses seins qu'elle
serait bien mais là pas le temps de le
faire mais c'est une hitman sarah sa
date aucune expression quoi elle est
très tranquille ce terrible
ce terrifiant fait
franchement elle te fait peur non
j'ai quasiment on la voit sourire entre
les parties quand elle discute un peu
mais sinon on a l'impression que ça va
bien se passer un terrible c'est
terrible maxime qui a récupéré les
résultats sur des premiers matches mais
ça pas mal joué franchement des premiers
matches ça fait plaisir max de devoir de
voir où il fallait un bon niveau
ça fait plaisir quoi ils ont vraiment
elle a vraiment bien joué kosteniuk
après c'était trop facile
c'était pas un bon match on n'a pas
énormément regarder ça jouer assez mal
mais mais oui fans vraiment c'était ses
propres ce qu'elle a fait on a vu quels
saints peut à juste à internet elle a
trouvé la bonne connexion et je trouve
que c'est un peu le niveau au dessus on
va voir ce que ça donne là mais sarah ça
te fait une bonne première partie là
mathieu évidemment comme d'habitude
n'est pas dans le chat mais bon on
comprend que ces prépas sont sont sur
une telle calamité que peut-être que
c'est pas lui qui a préparé ce matin
quoi d'ailleurs elle est déjà mieux
sarah sadate
non mais c'est très dur la jouer pour
les blancs parce qu'il ya des quatre qui
est faible isolé il ya 5 qui est faible
c'est terrible sarah là qui fait
vraiment une bonne première partie
on va voir
oui je veux pas dire mais quand à la
sortie la semi ruiz qui n'est bien sûr
pas une prépa de mathieu ça allait
beaucoup ignoraient c'est vrai que dès
qu'elle est sortie des prépas de mathieu
hier ça s'est beaucoup mieux passé pour
alain c'est vrai que du moment qu'elle a
décidé de plus jouer les prépas elle a
enfin réussi à avoir des bonnes
positions
calé lien entre sarah et mathieu on ne
sait pas s'ils démentent et regarde donc
on va dire que c'est la prépa c'est quoi
une saignée ruiz une ouest indienne
c'est s'arrête à zolder c'est mathieu
qui la prépare
les packs e enfin si si mais bon on peut
pas on peut pas s'empêcher d'un peu d'un
peu chambré mathieu surtout qu'il n'est
pas dans le tchat
donc écouter c'est dur pour jouer à une
junqua valiant f4 qui attaquent g2 la
dame qui est venu attaquer le pion bk de
protéger le pion des quatre attaques
aient fait tour à
pour des huit tours d un état d'âme des
cinq le retour pour mettre une pression
sur à 5 maintenant
bams et 7 et sur dame prend des 4l veut
cavaliers detroit et chez crest ça fait
une découverte
donc j'ai trois quarts et d5 et prend
tout reprendra me prend bk dans cet
ordre là est-ce que ça gagne encore
cette histoire elle doit ouest eut fait
dame prend dame prend tout reprend roigé
deux tours des cinq rois f-35 3,3 tu
arrive juste à temps
donc tu dois pour moi c'était ça ma tête
je me trompe pas répondre à une critique
c'était ça et si tu arrives à revenir ça
doit être nul puisque j'avais retenu du
dvd avec vlad en fait cette histoire
c'est que les finales sur réussi à venir
ça fait nul mais peut-être je me trompe
en gros dans les finales avec le pion
isolé ce ton roi se rapproche du pion et
que les tours sont protégés ça fait nul
comme ça c'est d'être trop à mon avis
attend tour des 6 e 5 encore ok mais on
fera des 5
on va rapprocher le roi est ok on peut
faire ça on peut mettre la tour en a
cinq mêmes et on va rapprocher le roi et
ça va faire mieux
il ya un pion de moi mais ça fait 4
contre wade drôle je suis peut-être allé
un peu fort quand même c'est nul mais ça
va jouer ça va jouer ça a bien sûr joué
à fond mais c'est censé être nulle
les cavaliers detroit un moment donné
quand je me suis perdu sans rien savoir
j'avais pas avoir actuellement les
caisses et 3 a peut-être ici avec l'idée
sur b prend ces trois baies france et 3
et d'attaquer un peu tout et pas
toujours injuste qui avait lieu de roy
boujut télé prend des 4es il ya eu un
cavalier ces trois ratés effectivement
qui n'était pas facile à voir surtout
qu'ils gagnent et qu'un pion
c'était pas facile à voir ce que ça
gagner qu'un pion en fait je trouve ces
plusieurs de voir ce genre de tactique
quand ça gagne peu de matériel et
sûrement faire rager un vrai c'est pas
si facile à voir évidemment pour 1m vlc
tempo mais bon elle va faire s'annulant
elle défend bien normal joue bien les
haleines bonne technique jouer jones et
c'est juste que j'apprécie vraiment toi
réussissent ici qu'aux f5 elle va
repartir avec la tour et si le roi
montaut qui avoir faire échec mais elle
peut se faire faire tomber
malheureusement de ce qu'elle peut avoir
ses problèmes de connexion aussi 3g 2 3
bon là c'est nul de chez nul mais ya
toujours le temps est ce que tu peux
échanger je ne changerai jamais ça non
tu pouvais pas est-ce qu'elle va tomber
ou pas sarah sadate qui essaye de la
faire tomber
avec le sourire matour g4 à elle va elle
va tomber j'ai bien peur à ces terribles
c'est terrible la connexion à ces jeunes
je peux pas voir ça les gars ah non elle
perd une nouvelle fois la connexion à
ces terribles
c'est terrible de voir ça les amis c'est
dur parce que c'est dur parce que quand
même tu veux voir des échecs et kanté
spectateurs elle se fait pas faire
tomber part parce que parce qu'elle joue
pas assez vite ou quoi juste à la une
moins bonne connexion on nous a expliqué
que les joueurs chinois peuvent devoir
utiliser des vpn pour pour se connecter
à zoomer pour partager la caméra et
c'est ça qui fait ramener un peu leur
connexion apparemment et c'est vrai que
je trouve que c'est cesser c'est dommage
pour la compacte ce genre de choses
parce que là avec une connexion normal
nous allait elle se laisse pas ton elles
se trompent pas quoi après c'est le jeu
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas à critiquer
sarah sadate
sarah elle fait le taff elle utilise
qu'elle peut utiliser un voile pudique
sur l'épaule mais avec le vpn ouais ça
fait une mauvaise connexion ya rien à
faire le vpn tutu l'agra toujours un
petit peu avec un vpn
c'est elle peut rien y faire en fait à
moins d'avoir une autorisation du
gouvernement chinois peut être mais je
pense pas qu'ils lui donnent un je pense
pas qu'ils me donnent
mark a eu quatre
twitch autorisé en chine d'ailleurs et
je sais pas je crois qu'ils ont leurs
propres tweets que j'ai lu une histoire
comme ça ils ont leur propre réseau de
streaming et je crois que si un
occidental stream la chaîne peut se
faire ban
j'ai lu un truc comme ça sur twitter à
vérifier mais il ya un joueur de faith
connexion et et sites ont fait ce truc
aux niches est et occidentale pas de
chance
pas de chance la chaîne se fait plus ou
moins ottomane j'ai lu un truc comme ça
sur twitter à vérifier mais ça
m'étonnerait pas en soi c'était rien
c'est horrible
et tout y est bloqué en chine aussi ré
c'est terrible bon du coup cette
position qui nous ce qui nous sort d'un
gang d'un d'une ouest indienne un genre
de il n'y a pas d'âme 8 ici dan 17 et
gens fous a approuvé cette à le bessin a
nommé sting gaffe qu'elle aille ajuste
dame des sept noms du coup c'est une
pièce non elle ne pouvait pas plutôt
faire dame prend qu'à rallier prend b5
pour essayer de la jouer c'était spécial
ça y est c'est dommage de feeling caisse
comme ça quand même
bon ça met un peu de baume au coeur à
jouer jun du cours qui revient à un
partout
on va regarder juste le score dans
l'autre match par curiosité et c ou chez
nina qui a pris l'idée intéressant à hô
chi minh ha ouais ou chez nina si elle
retourne encore en demie à la gagner un
tournoi elle a fait une finale si elle
fait encore une demi elle c'est sûr
qu'elle y sera dans la grande finale du
speech est ce pas elle fait quand même
des supers résultats quoi surtout que
ségou nina qui fait pareil cas elle donc
les autres prennent pas trop de points
si là elle va encore en demi salut qu'à
juste ceux d'hier trot monté
commentaires merci au tce street bat le
match aller avec aux siens pour avoir
les bons commentaires faut avoir le
match qui va avec
bao china qui met la daronne à l'abri en
revanche je la voyais pas aussi forte
moscheni la met à jouer vraiment bien
bah ça fait toujours la même tête ouais
ouais alors il ya aussi un peu plus de
monde parce qu'une petite premières
pages lues digues pour ça qu'un peu plus
de monde aujourd'hui c'est pas une
première page de folie mais ça paraît
toujours 2 2 ramené à un peu plus de
chance par la première palme tout à tout
le monde qu'ils tombent dessus mais ça
permet d'avoir un petit peu plus de
monde
aller face à rennes l'âge des sourires
en daumeray
vraiment ça a pas l'air de beaucoup
rigoler dans la maison sahara on la lit
mathieu il doit pas et ne doit pas trop
rigoler avec ans et prépare rentre pas
ce que c'est souvent le cas quand même
g4
je partir en h4 par réflexe pour
échanger ce cavalier je sais pas et
j'aurais l'impression d'affaiblir un peu
plus
bon ok des six états tâche 3 du coût
car à lille 5-4 bien joué ça parce que
sur vous prend vous prend vous prend ce
n'est même pas forcé mais peut-être tu
pourrais jouer les cases noires mais
attend peut-être sur vous prend pour
jouer puis on prend plutôt où tout
reprend même comme ça sur fou prend les
atours prend 1,7
ça a l'air mieux ça et essayer de jouer
les cases noires autour du roi
c'est bien joué ça parle beaucoup à part
jouer john la province était bien la
prépa après bof on sait pas un mathieu
nous tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'hier
quand elle a arrêté de jouer la prépa ça
s'est mieux passé
c'est tout ce qu'on sait c'est tout ce
qu'on peut dire c'est clair quand elle a
arrêté de jouer ce que tu lui avait dit
ça ça a commencé à beaucoup mieux se
passer pour elle la joueuse iranienne
qui a pris les bonnes décisions 1
la joueuse iranienne qui a pris les
bonnes décisions hier et qui finalement
dans la partie la plus importante du
match l'armageddon à défier a décidé de
renier son coach et de et de jouer par
elle même et c'est vraiment ça qui l'a
fait gagner mais ce qu'elle va rééditer
la même expérience aujourd'hui balle est
toujours là
en tout cas tout va bien ici ouais ça se
passe pas mal mais qui en d3 bien placé
mais bon ça va c'est un peu plus
agréable pour les blancs mais sait rien
de ces rames dramatique 1 ça tient sajoo
ça va si deux prépa sur trois non moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle sorte des
prépas mathieu je cherche un très belle
aux juifs qui en bois tu connais une
marque ou un modèle à bâle face chacun
motivated apprentiss alpha échec
il y a qu un mot il n'y a qu'un mot
kaïs et 5 faut faire gaffe si le jour il
ya cavaliers d'inquiéter si ça va encore
aller mais faut le b3 assez 4 me fait
quand même super peur par ici on va voir
je suis un peu inquiet pour ça ça date
ouais bah kibaki bientôt bientôt
milliardaire donne bientôt millionnaire
s'il n'est pas déjà abaissées si on
regarde le nombre des chantiers qui vend
entre ça et maxime qui obligeait de le
payer une fortune pour les prépas il est
bien le père baky un faut faire gaffe
aussi aux caraïbes 4 qui peuvent rodez
en fait il peut ya peut-être des cahiers
des six comprend des sisters prend des
six cars a lieu quatre qui peuvent être
chiant tout réussit ce qui est pro f 6
puis on prend un f6 ça peut tenir de
justesse
bon pas facile de trouver un coup en
fait pour les noirs et b6 que c'est une
option
peut-être c'est une option v6 à la phase
mais coûte pourquoi pas
ok monts altaï qui doit repartir en d6
je pense pas son secret bécistes avoir
du c4 il ya quatre noms truc comme ça la
dame est enfermé donc ça on peut pas qui
est qui doit repartir en d6 et là il ya
fou prend des six tours prend des 6es
cavalier e 4 c'est terrible du coup elle
fait cavalier à 5 mais maintenant il ya
poussé cette et à quatre c'est encore
pire
ouais c'est terrible parce que fout ses
sept tours ces 8es à 4 l a pas vu auquel
veut dame prend aux deux dames prend à
eux deux et tout reprend meilleur ab4 à
la fin et cavaliers enfermé c'est
terrible
si elle fait tout reprend ça peut encore
jouer mais si elle fait dame prend tout
reprend b4 b6 attaque le cavalier et qui
avait lieu quatre attaques le fou
c'est fini
c'est fini donc est ce qui a encore une
partie ça dépend si elles ont commencé à
l'heure ou pas les autres il se passe
quoi dans l'autre match on peut aller
jeter un oeil en profiter ou chez nina
temps et on va aller on va aller voir
donc apparemment elle elle redémarre pas
ça a dû commencer à l'heure aujourd'hui
du coup c'est mieux que les que les 15
minutes de retard d'hier et elles elles
viennent de commencer leur troisième
partie ça m'étonnerait pas qui encore
une partie 1 dans le match de sa race à
date sont quand même une partie qui
s'est terminée rapidement
bon
apparemment l'autre match l'hôte match
est en pause donc il reste plus que
celui là je vous montre à la camsa rakia
sur le sourire malgré tout je voulais
une journée aussi j'ai envie de te dire
et ça joue de l'autre côté
donc ça ça sort d'une petrov cette
petite prise au centre qui est
intéressante pour les blancs
alors
comment ça va se passer
comment ça se passait ici est ce que les
blancs vont réussir à presser ou pas non
ça va changer
normalement il va rien et avoir un yack
une colonne ouverte n'y a pas de jeu
bush et nina solide
alors non ça relou de l'autre côté bah
c'est extraordinaire il ya une pause de
trois minutes et c'est reparti on sait
pas pourquoi ce match là qui va durer 1
ces matches là qui vont durer qui vont
prendre du retard bond bizarre mais
c'est comme ça je crois qu'ils mettent
les matchs en pause quand il ya un
problème de connexion je sais pas parce
que là ça a dépassé les 30 minutes c'est
sûr
mesdames ces deux d'accord
c'est cinq escales à faire re 4 pour
jouer un genre des taux de marc auxi
donc mathieu qui cas il se rappelle de
rien évidemment dans le chat pour se
dédouaner d'une d'une préparation
complètement ratée de sa part évidemment
mais elle va faire quatre là non c'est
bizarre non foulée cette housse et moi
tu mets pas le pion au 4t content il ya
pas qu il prend des cinq là bas mais je
dois rien voir parce qu'elle prendrait 5
c'est un pion quand même de base y'a
quoi il ya dame eu quatre médailles le
cas de double attaque qui a pas juste
dames 7
je comprends rien fu bessette c'était
eux quatre le coup logique qui est là
bon il ya peut-être un peu d'activité
mais c'est peut-être de l'activité est
peut-être la prépare il peut y avoir de
l'activité se fait en gambie c'est
peut-être un gambit pour l'activité mais
bizarre quand même non enfin je sais pas
il nous faudrait des gens plus à l'idée
existe mais si c'est pas très bon non
mais l'idée j'ai déjà vu évidemment vlad
m'avait montré
et oui il y avait bien un ko 4
paraissait juste hyper logique je te
mettais en face du fou c'est une des
grandes idées quand tu joues contre le
fatah avait l'air content parce que du
coup le fou il était venu en asie' s'il
revenait en bessette pour se mettre là
et tu pouvais long mur et est souvent
c'est un truc que tu aimes bien faire
contre les west indienne qu en le
fouillant baissait de l'emmurer donc ça
paraissait très logique
mais bon ce n'est pas mauvais en ce
qu'elle fait au final
c'était pas si mauvais pascal a pas mal
d'activités ça a le mérite de mettre en
difficulté jouanne john qui a peut-être
plus de mal à jouer dans cette position
là
on va voir on a déjà des six qui retombe
qu'elle dispose de faire une partie à
96,2 précise ruiz pas grand-chose à
93,93 soul you c'est largement possible
retour en d1 pas mal
on va voir
je vais line tour d intéressant quand
même mais un truc qui le tama 4 murray
sera pas à l'esa
du coup elle a fait d'âme des uns comme
ça surtout prend 1,4 at on prend des
cette logique tant des huit donc il ya
toujours lui sous pression
on a peut-être toi
protéger le pion et la tête cavalier e 5
proposait les changes détour et bien
vissé la case de cinq ans et ça a l'air
d'aller 1 pour jouer john va jeter un
oeil à l'autre partie par curiosité qui
semble plutôt ouais ça va pour les noirs
mais faire attention beaucoup tuant sur
noir quand même peut-être du coup
échangés en d2 à elle veut essayer de
faire des quatre tours d'étroites on
prend à 3 tu as donc comme b5 c'est
intéressant puis on prend tout reprendre
il ya peut-être ces sept en l'air
le têt tourer elle c'est marrant ça
est-ce que la finale deux tours à aller
avec le plan roi des deux rois ces trois
b 4 que d'aller chercher c'est
intéressant
b 5 pions prend tout reprend tour ces
trois tours prend des cinq tours prend
cc3f 8 toi c'est toi et c'est chiant je
pense que katiavala gagne allez on va
retourner vers l'autre match il ya eu le
cavalier seul dont on parle est bon
c'est chaud c'est tendu
écoutez bien jouer motivator d'apprentis
ce alors là ya pas qu il prend f3 l'idée
c'est que sur dame prend il ya fou prend
des 5 tu pourras pas prendre du plomb la
tour sera attaqué dont tu dois prendre
de g et maintenant n'importe quel coût
n'importe joreige si disons et les
blancs une mauvaise structure c'est
hyper logique 1 dans l'autre match or
cette finale elle donne quoi il va ya
voir toi tour un tour tour aussi ça va
gagner pour katia el harrachi salaires
fort hachey salaire très fort et toits
tours 7
il n'y a jamais de pattes parce que le
pion c'est peu bougé ya passé cinq
échecs à m'aider c'est on prend ces sept
ya ap il ya les deux pions qui file à je
sais pas si elle avait vu à l'avant ça
ok et maintenant ses sets 3-6 souhaite
bien jouer katia joli d'avoir laissé la
touche pas et c'était volontaire
il n'y a pas de pattes parce que là
n'avaient pas sur la 7e elle va faire
ton france et 7 et la fera pas prendre
de la dame mais du roi et maintenant ces
abandons ok donc ça c'est égalité ok
sarah salades par contre c'est terrible
c'est terrible mais n'hésitent pas à
demander que baky te fasses mutualité
d'apprentis c'est une petite petite
dédicace salua dark the third dans le
chat donc match serré de l'autre côté on
va voir ce que ça donne côté sarah
sadate jouanne john mais jouer john qui
peut faire l'écart les amis elle peut
partir pour faire l'écart joue la finale
de dame elle est quand même très bien
pour elle elle devrait pouvoir prendre
deux points d'écart puisque adam prend
b2 et c 4 ça semble envoyer le pion
assez violemment tout cas ça fait
beaucoup de sens
donc
elle a pris plutôt f3a est là elle va
perdre à 5 ans + sarah sa date mais elle
va regagner la case de 5 ce qui peut
être intéressant
j'arrive même pas il ya ces quatre
mesdames france et 4 maintenant est ce
plutôt bien ce qui se passe pour l
amitié toi mon histoire aussi prendre le
t-shirt ça se passe moins mal que prévu
pour ça
bref ça qu'ils avaient essayé de ramener
son roi ça va jouer à un moment l'un
heureusement pour sarah qui a les
problèmes de connexion à côté chinois
sinon le score serait encore plus lourd
c'est vrai que je vois une zone a perdu
tellement de points que ses problèmes de
connexion laférois f5 c'est sûr je pense
je pense qu'elle est en hausse 6 1 elle
est repartie angers7
elle s'est un peu emmêlé les pinceaux
avec les noirs mais voilà pouvoir jouer
ça des plombes
ça c'est bien joué elle s'est créée un
pion passé en plus ça va et le pion b ou
là elle va revenir en g4 et dames ces
quatre échecs voilà lui a tout fait
sarah qui abandonnent et ça fait ça fait
deux points d'écart ça fait beaucoup
pour pour la joueuse iranienne quand
même on va voir si elle remonte mais
joue à jude impérial je vais faire une
toute petite pause je vous remets la
partie en entier la dernière convient de
suivre et on se retrouve on se retrouve
dans trois petites minutes a tout de
suite
à
les vaincus de retour sarah salat et là
je sais pas si son retour d'adia
longtemps montré elle rigole elle rigole
à fond fait-elle souris entre les
parties j'ai compris maintenant
maintenant j'ai compris le délire
trente secondes rsa date ça date pas ça
t'a dit a longtemps le retour de sarah
salat
bon j'aurais pas compris grand chose au
move d'échec en passant par là mais
j'aurais au moins vu le charme des
femmes iraniennes c'est pas une légende
ouais bah faut mieux que tu viennes sur
un autre hymne là c'est pas c'est faux
mieux que tu passe demain soir ou taille
sur ma chaîne youtube quoi lasser s'est
pas vraiment pour les gens qui débutent
pas forcément le meilleur endroit quand
on garde une compétition pro qui est pas
non plus forcément ultra passionnante
pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment le
meilleur endroit pour les débutants
débutants quoi malheureusement il y aura
d'autres compétitions plus plus cool
quoi j'imagine un joli de se battre car
l'autre à mauvaise connexion mais voilà
c'est ça l'esprit des coachs aujourd'hui
tôt crasse 333 jeu faut je repasserai
way essaye de follow ma chaîne perso tu
auras plus de contenu qui te plaira nuxe
tu as le lien juste en dessous c'est
bitstream notamment ce soir on va bien
rigoler mais tu t'es tu t'amuseras plus
ça
tu t'amuseras plus
donc ça va repartir les amis la même je
comprends pas et j'ai même pas la fois
de mettre aux échecs tellement je pars
de loin il faut comprendre où là il ya
une guêpe qui vient attention sur les
ennemis d une quête qui arrivent non non
mais je vais peut-être devoir partir le
légat non non non non je n'aime pas du
tout ça veut dire repart je suis très
très méfiant des guêpes
elle sera la présence de super bits sans
plus mais ça va être terrible
ça va être terrible ce soir voir est-ce
que ça repart
ouais ça repart alors attends katia
c'est parce qu'on veut sarah sadate
wait and see 14 est comme ça passe bien
ouais ouais bon ce tranquille c'est
tranquille ou bon ok c'est un truc
symétrique l'a de nouveau le cas et qui
vient au f5 du coup ça va s'en prendre
espions là mais boris ou cas il arrive
boris ou cas il arrive dimanche bon
c'est structure de type karo kann il ya
une pièce en trop pour les noirs après
cet échange encore on va voir
gens qui connaissent pas trop super
blitz un dans le tchat ce calme
étonnante pas connaître ce super héros
quand même bien connu je dise tu veux
jouer cavalier h 6 essence et 6 elle a
fait quoi
valve a fait ces 6es cavaler h 6 mai
c'est fou en fait franchement faut que
t'arrêtes les prépare un mathieu je
pense qu'elle joue mieux quand elle joue
pas tes prépa et qu'elle joue par
elle-même 1 je pense qu'elle joue mieux
quand elle je sais pas pourquoi a faim
je pense je pense vraiment que que
qu'elles se débrouillent mieux sans toi
non mais franchement
c'est peut-être tu dois arrêter juste de
la préparer pour son bien bon et joue
pas mal quand même
imagine si mathieu devenu coach des
abonnés ouais mais ce serait la cata
total déjà qu'on perd tous les matches
là en fait on va perdre pas tous les
matches on a perdu 6,9 fois qu'on a
perdu 7 on en a gagné 2 mai mais ce soir
on va gagner ce soir c'est sûr qu'on
gagne ce soir c'est sûr qu'on va gagner
de façon sinon il y aura masse de bane
dans le tchad donc on n'a pas trop le
choix
pas trop le choix mais ce soir c'est sûr
qu'on gagne bon mais là ça a plus ou
moins exposition bon à la des pions
doublé mais c'est pas bien grave
c'est pas bien grave allez un p'tit gars
va l'aider katla qui les prend tous
reprend et on s'en prend aux pions g4
franchement ça peut aller 1
ça peut le faire
qui est des quatre ça va aller en fait
je vois que ça commence mal le match
pour me faire battre je quitte mais je
crois que tu vas jouer en premier
elliott
donc je pense que le ban
si on perd tu vas y passer un après si
tu gagnes ta partie aura pas de ban
donc de toute façon tranquille ouais mon
avis ça va aller mais ça va à laquelle
prend des cartons qu'on des cats à
l'aide dans la sarre assalat comprend
des cats a l'air cool les tours 17 on
revient après tu fais b5 b4 ou b5 direct
moi j'aime bien tu veux décider débat ne
max mais de toute façon dans tous les
cas si l'équipe perd tous les perdants
doivent être ban
ça c'est évident il n'y a pas d' adam et
d'un français 3 d'un premier 5 dame
prend 1 mais a pas d'âme preneurs en un
mais c'est une tour ça madame
et ben voilà sarasar être qui sourit un
petit peu et ben voilà sarah salade qui
retrouvent le sourire pour la par
exemple c'est quand même ban 72 heures
pour un truc comme ça et si on gagne on
en bane quelques-uns quand même non je
pense pas non si on gagne on est grand
seigneur je pense on gagne pas mais là
peut-être 4 quand même
peut-être 4 quand même c'est quand même
logique quoi ça protège le pion et ça
bloque le fou barral
c est quand même perdre le pion mais au
moins tu as mis la dame en pls
sajoo commence histoire dajka mali prend
est fou detroit mais y'aura c4 ce que
ces quatre cinq ou six français quatre
dames prend 1,4 on va voir
à la prépa qui est suivi ça sent la
deffe états d'âme et dans l'autre match
c'est hyper chaud l'autre match il est
bouillant l'autre match ça à partir en
dames trois dames g5 c'est chaud un des
deux côtés on va rester sur notre match
à nous ça a pas bougé après fou des
trois c4 me paraît logique mais bon
non mais les gagnants vont pas prendre
de ban en cas de défaite de l'équipe
kamsing au début quoi on va on va à
l'essai des chances on va attendre
quelques semaines avant de passer avant
de passer au ban des faits pour tous les
perdants faut que les gens de s'habituer
à un petit peu il faut quand même que si
l'équipe gagne ça sauve les gens quoi ah
ouais elle a perdu sa connexion joue à
une joue exactement
ouais c'est ça le problème en fait elle
est encore connectés à zoom on voit sa
caméra donc c'est pour ça que je pensais
pas la déco mais avec le vpn elle perd
là que la déco et ouais c'est bien joué
de la part de sarah ça joue sur la co
voilà pauvre joué john l'armée c'est
terrible a déjà perdu contre goût ni
n'assure sur connexion est là elle va
reperdre encore sur connexion quoi c'est
terrible c'est terrible
c'est terrible si tu joue en équipe de
beauté elle mais elle est ce que tu es
ban
si ton équipe r oui si l'équipe de
beauté ce gagne non mais si l'équipe de
voter ce père oui tu seras ban
bien sûr sera dépendant du sort de
l'équipe de beauté l accord d ouais mais
de façon tu vas souffrir contre est lui
atteint les doigts tu vas faire le taf
un teint kg est pas inquiète pas pour ça
par contre si tu perds avec l'équipe de
beauté est à partie même si l'équipe de
beauté ce père tu seras pas ban
s'il ya aussi cette finesse
bref c'est thiaroye des huit la paroisse
province est bêtement voilà ça va pour
les noirs mais faut que sarah joue vite
juste là faut juste jouer vite avec les
blancs et faire tomber faut jouer la
connexion en fait là faut jouer la coi à
fond si tu joues si tu joues tout tempo
elle va forcément finir par tomber tu
fais tour des cinq fait autour des 1 tu
fais f prend 2,3 tu prêt mauvais tu va
la faire tomber
est-ce que les vannes sont rétroactifs
oui oui bien sûr les balles sont
rétroactifs évidemment de toute façon
les gens qui sont bahn vont être noté
bien évidemment donc s'il ya des gens
qui essayent de fuir évidemment les
vannes sont rétroactifs ça c'est clair
il faut vraiment qu'elle joue vite la
sara ces ajouts vital gagnera
ces ajouts vitalia n'y aura elle est
tour à tour ces deux tours des deux
tours des six tailles à b5 qui gagne au
nom elle rate une pièce en a les amis
moi je le redis pour me le montrer je
mets un petit peu mais quand même c'est
dommage de prendre beaucoup de temps
pour jouer beaucoup de coups et puis de
de jouer tempo le coup qui te faisait
gagner quoi
c'est dommage en fait puisque tu pouvais
la gagner sur un coup là well as une
minute après je comprends en fait elle
veut faire tomber donc à elle à elle
joue vite
elle a joué vite mais en fait elle a
joué le vix levitt le coup il fallait
pas jouer vite quoi c'est terrible bon
elle va quand même gagné l'autre est
trop mal autant mais c'est du rhin pour
jouer john qui malgré les problèmes de
connexion malgré tous les problèmes
réussi à avoir une position correcte
quoi en gros c'est complètement nul
elle a réussi à tenir avec en ayant
perdu deux minutes vingt dans la
connexion
elle joue avec 40 secondes contre 3
minutes au début de la partie et une
mauvaise connexion
donc c'est quand même assez
impressionnant ce qu'elle réussit à
faire je vous l ai vraiment beaucoup
plus forte à sarah qui propose nul
refusé par jour donc fair-play sarah
joue qui re propose nul au kef est fair
play ça rassure celle là mais grosse
défense de joie c'est dommage de rater
le b 5 quand même c'est quand même très
très dommage d'avoir raté ce que ça lui
permettait de gagner la partie
immédiatement
c'est vraiment dommage et dans l'autre
match bon toujours tendue il n'y a qu'un
point d'écart après qu'ils allaient
change
il va y avoir cassé 6 peut-être tour ses
huit cavaliers à 5
non j'ai testé fair play c'était c'était
bien joué c'était bien joué a laissé
repartir cavalière à 5 tours c'est 8
j'ai juste un temps sur le chrono
puisque j'ai un peu perdu là avec ses
problèmes de connexion et où j'ai un peu
perdu le fil de la compétition et j'ai
envie de dire ça y est on est on est
ouais ok il reste encore du temps il
reste encore beaucoup de temps il reste
encore 15 8 dans cette cadence ils
savent encore jouer trois parties
allaient là elle peut prendre en d5
jouer sur les cloisons multiples sur
cavaliers prend il ya fou prend b2 sur
pions prend il ya fou prend à eux deux
donc les deux pièces qui protège le pion
des cinq sont cloués à l'écart et prends
des seins qu'elle peut le voir elle l'a
vu c'est bien joué ça de la part de
sarah
mais la sara qui prend un gros avantage
dans cette partie elle va pouvoir
égaliser à la ciel joue bien sarah elle
revient à la marque donc la foux prend à
eux deux puis il faut prendre b2 le
double clouage sur les diagonales
ça fait très mal c'est vraiment bien
joué là de la part de sarah et ça va se
gagner un peu tout seul cette histoire
en plus que le pion des cinq maintenant
est faible fou qui a peut-être revenir
en effet si ça paraît logique dame 17
c'est bien aussi
je vais voir tour des huit fois f6 c'est
très bien pour ça qu'il a une vraie
balle d'égalisation mais peut-être le
cavalier du cou qui doit revenir en jeu
aussi
le fou kenyan f6 et être le cavalier qui
va rejaillir vers ses cinq fils adam
verra quatre pour attaquer à de sf4
mais ça c'est bien joué
elle vise la casse ces six maintenant
que cavalier partie très bons coups de
la part de joue très bien joué
prise cinq prises 5 mais attention hein
paroisse et fit pour défendre le pion
durée d'un match 8 matt carle et des six
bien jouer sur d'un procès à tours 8
dame prend 17 pour prend 1,20 h3t
maintenant peut-être tour 8,1 pour
défendre finalement
parce qu'il ya plus trop le choix car il
y avait cinq ya peut-être des g4 qui
partent
elle fait damas quatre packs ondama 4
carole alors dit donne un joli coup ses
cavaliers h5 a quitté sur pions prend de
faire dame j'ai cinq échecs sur walfoot
adam prend un c'est donc il faut revenir
et maintenant dames 5 f si ces dames 3e
set mais très difficile à voir
j'aurais jamais trouvé ça tu peux le
voir mais c'est dur de comprendre que ça
à faire perpète
elle le voit où on est très bien joué de
la part de ge ou les amis qu'ils
trouvent cavaliers h5
oui c'est beau ça ça c'est très bien
joué de la part de joux et dans l'autre
match katia qui égalise qui revient
ouais ça s'est vraiment bien joué un
écart et les f-5 sa perle manqué cinq
sages ou g4 mais un cavalier h5 très
joli coin j'aime vraiment comment 12
juin
je la trouve vraiment forte 7 jouent
alors elle peut peut-être faire plutôt
dame province est d'ailleurs tour huit
dames f6 d'alger cinq dames f6 damage ci
va y avoir perpète
c'est vraiment très très bien joué ce
cavalier h5 qui n'était pas facile à
voir
fallait y penser
bien joué la serpette belle défense à
zhu qui sauve la nulle de fort belle
manière
ouais là c'est joli sauvetage vraiment
je vous ai dis hein ça c'est une joueuse
qui joue bien ça fait plaisir de la
suivre c'était c'était décevant qu'elle
ait des problèmes de connexion c'est
vraiment une excellente joueuse je
trouve que c'est vraiment plaisant de
suivre de suivre ces partis mais du coup
c'est une dose de déception d'avoir ces
problèmes de connexion que ce soit pour
pour jouer ou pour uni fans
c'était très décevant et c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu nui à l'intérêt à
l'intérêt des tournois et c'est une
bonne chose que cons et qu'on ait
retrouvé quelques zéros trouver une
connexion tout cas plus potable n'y
avait nulle part échec perpétue altafini
patrick la partie aurait pu continuer de
manière infinie avec les mêmes échecs
donc la petite position de gambie dame
qu'affectionne sarah salat
on va voir s'ils jouent réussi à régler
le problème du fou ces huit ans qui est
la mauvaise pièce ici pour les noirs qui
obstruent complètement la tour et qui
sert à rien on va voir si elle réussit à
se débarrasser de ce problème
allez peut-être du fou eu deux fois f3
c'est un plan que j'adore dans cette
structure là pour les blancs plan très
classique
je trouve ça dommage tout le foin et
grand c4 est très mal placé parce qu'il
tape sur un mur alors qu'en b3 il te
bloquer le le développement du fouet je
pense faut de cet effort jeu parce qu'en
pense le coach il faut deux fois f3 dans
ses positions
c'est un plan simple on voit que le
football est roi ici les justes mal
placée en fait
on va voir ce qu'elle donne
on va essayer de pousser au centre
qui accueille en c4
mathieu qui sut complètement devant
l'écran
c'est pas de pions blancs sur eux et pas
être écrit go la base 2 qui prend 1,7
foods 6 ouais bon ça marche rarement en
finale quand même puis a surtout un pion
le même c'est juste dommage de ne pas
avoir joué l'enfermement
bon là ça va hein ça joue les blancs
sont pas moins bien mais le pion c4 un
peu faible a perdu fou de l'autre côté
voilà ce que ça donne
machin très énervé bon alors qu'avait
lieu 5 et prend 1,5 jouer ça échange
n'est donc il va y avoir d'un côté la
paire de fou
et et là de l'autre côté il va ya voir
ça contre pions c4 fait voir ce que ça
donne à voir ce que ça donne
peut-être plus agréable à jouer pour les
blancs carrément blitz en tout cas ce
que ceux qui ont ces quatre il peut être
facilement perdable alors que les blancs
ils n'ont pas vraiment de risque de se
retrouver moins bien fou qui va repartir
en 3 pts être inquiet b1 qui est des
deux
ça peut être pénible à quai à capter ces
cinq aussi qui peut exister comme plan
mais à cette belle cible en c4 ce pion
qui est un peu seul sac il ya quatre ça
peut être sympa pour venir en c5 faire
mal en fait il peut toucher ça il coupe
la connexion mais non qui a quatre qui
et b6 aussi web maintenant qu'il ya plus
le fou sarah lac et une bonne bonne
position
elle met vraiment jouable jun sous
pression
non mais vraiment sous pression à fond
maintenant tourbe et 8 elle va pouvoir
prendre le pion à la une très bonne
position
la petit coup comme b3 peuvent être
intéressants parfois pour blinder fous
ces cinq bien joué elle va la gagner ça
là je pense elle va égaliser un sahara
ouais on était des fois sb3 c'est bien
joué peut-être des fous à sept cavaliers
ces cinq cas il prend 17 revenir avec le
fouet jouer celle là avec le bon fou
contre le mauvais fou j'ai moins aimé
car elle et ses trois mails valant des
cinq ça a l'air bien juste elle elle se
laisse m dans la lignée de la tour elle
a raté le poème bal avec fois c'est à
toi est séparée c'est sympa le fou mvele
bon à le rendre dans la finale mais ce
cas les six simples la finale de pièces
mineur parce que le truc c'est hamas de
pions sur blanc
si ce gars à un jour rentrer il peut
faire une rasé quoi et en plus tu peux
pas être changées fou de cases noires
contre cavaliers ça joue bien et depuis
quelques mois
oh c'est très bien joué ça c'est bien là
ce qu'elle fait ça et maintenant j'ai
h&h 6h 7h 8 ouais ça joue vraiment pas
mal
ça joue vraiment pas mal ça agréable
c'est un bon match 1 c'est le bon match
de la journée et je pense si on est
tombé sur le bon match aussi de l'autre
côté
voilà c'est fini joux qui va la perdre
elle essaye de tenir encore comme elle
peut mais là le roi qui rentrera f6 à
non à leurs parents des quatre devaient
y avoir un problème ray pas sûr allez va
falloir passer par faire pousser cet
échec crois aussi sans elle recule le
roy on la joue et joonas plus de pions
prend 1,4 fou prend il ya trop de pions
il ya trop pions le roi qui arrive
angers7
c'est terminé c'est game et ça fait une
nouvelle victoire pour sarah qui égalise
les amis le match qui se tend égalité
parfaite entre les deux femmes
il reste combien de temps ouais c'est la
dernière partie de la cadence
on va juger jeter un oeil sur l'autre
match pour avoir le score
il ya 3 2 pour ou chez nina fait de voir
quand même la partie
dans l'autre match partie tendue ou chez
nina qui est un peu devant ben on va
voir là on est une petite ni mesure
indienne
alors là je t'annonce âge se rappellera
pas c'est sûr on va voir on va voir tout
cas ça joue bien là sur quelques parties
ça fait plaisir enfin un peu de un peu
de lait veulent de la part des deux
joueuses en même temps et ça c'est
plutôt sympa alors il ya eu g4 il ya eu
1 h 4
mais voir h5 g5 qui va arriver à fermer
tout cas en f4 cavalli la tourbe et un
tour à deux n'ont joué
elle a tout envoyé sur le roi joue à une
jaune c'est une vente marrant tu crois
que j'ai déjà vu des parties avec ça
avec toutes les pièces qui restent sur
la première et une attaque de ouf
j'imagine ça va être encore c'est pas
une idée georges pas si cette
position-là typique et et théorique mais
j'ai déjà vu ce 7e place alors que c'est
pas du tout moi et je sais pas du tout
mon répertoire
mais j'ai déjà vu des setups comme ça
avec les blancs qui développe quasiment
pas leurs pièces et qui font naviguer la
tour comme çà ou là quelqu'un et
quelqu'un qui s'est connecté au truc de
zoom qui manière de faire de la musique
parce qu'il foutait un broyage de l
belle sort le roi voilà pas eu le temps
de passer la tour de l'autre côté mais
ça a l'air très très tendu tout cas sans
voix jugent jeter un oeil à l'autre
partie parce que je vois que ça bouge là
beaucoup voyaient une pièce de plus pour
katia qui va ré égaliser dans le match
vous c'est serré 1 c'est dommage qu'on
n'ait pas eu que c'est dommage ça se
joue en même temps il eu peu de matchs
intéressants c'est dommage que que deux
matches intéressants se joue en même
temps bon allez on reste sur cette
partie moi j'aime bien les noirs un
perso vous avez déjà remarqué j'ai du
mal à avoir peur de ces attaques
ça me fait absolument pas peur avec les
noirs j'ai l'impression que quand les
pièces sont tellement d organiser ça
peut rien faire georges flore et
peut-être qu'à qui on prend et g5 ou car
il y prend d2 et g5 t'échange ont réussi
une fois mais j'arrive pas à avoir peur
en fait moi je vois un roux en f2 un peu
sale une tour on a de blizzard un
cavalier qui peut rejaillir
ça me fait pas du tout peur
ça ne me fait pas du tout peur chaque
étranger et 6 je te bouveret le pion je
remettrai la torah et fuite
je n'arriverai pas à avoir peur
honnêtement sans que le foin f1 est
triste j'adore les noirs en fait mais je
sais pas si objectivement les noirs sont
mieux mais cherche pas tous rêvent cette
tour des huit dames des huit au cas où
pour revenir avec les grandes gens de là
bas je trouve cette position excellente
pour les noirs dams et 7
j'aurais préféré doubler les tours et
essayer de passer avec les grandes
jambes par là bas à leurs parents à 5
c'est ballot quand même dame cette dame
à 5 parce qu'il pourrait y avoir des
dames 1 et la tour va pouvoir passer là
bas tous cas de dommages dames c'est
cette dame à 5 c'était quand même
dommage 1b s'inclinant ça va naviguer de
l'autre côté
bonjour avec m dames prend à 3 j'aurai
du mal à avoir peur
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à avoir peur
mais bon peut-être il faut il va y avoir
des fois h3d 2,6 il doit falloir avoir
peur de tout rachat tour age 2 j'imagine
qu'il doit falloir avoir peur pas de
façon avec les blancs si tu le fais pas
tu as ta aucune idée quoi commence
parfois h3 ok c'est pas con elle se dit
fou prend tout reprend et je le fais au
coup d'après je n'arrive pas à avoir
peur j'y peux rien bon là aussi c'est
peut-être sur roy prend pour essayer de
faire flouer 4 et qu'elle fait tout rage
suite c'est pas idiot quel est le truc
qui me fait peur c'est aussi sans vrai
ouais parce qu'eux aussi soient ramenés
une pièce en attaque en fait est un
machin d'un match 4 bon à voir c'est
très chaud les amis mais aussi c'est un
coin pour g8 way down décision à la
faire rager deux et ça va lui permettre
de passer la dame en h4
c'est bien moi j'ai deux noms ll choke
l'âge où elle joue une ça se voit sur
son visage tour h5 va être joué non ok
mais la dame h4 thiva quoi tu vois un
trou tu rentres gwangju qu'est tour
pranger cette dame h4 est peut-être pas
de mac dan des 8,3 ces six dames à 8,3
b6 tour des huit roissy soit et si j'en
trouve un math
tadam g3 aussi intéressant pour entre
ambert 8
adam h1 d'un creux trois dames achoui
qui avait touré fuite
mesdames g3 ça aurait été mieux et la
dame h3 maintenant et ça se retourne et
d'un machin tour eiffe tour g1 et seimat
moi j'ai trois tours g2 d'impro
d'apprendre indirects mais peut-être que
là en fait peut-être que là y'avait
d'alger 3 qui était pas mal qui
permettait de rentrer en belgique et
elle a eu la même idée avec ta machin
mais ça ça pénétrait - parce qu'ils
avaient damage 5 twh 5 pardon alors que
dame g3 ça faisait très mal mais wife
froid là et tu peux t'assurer c'était
choquant parce que dams et 7
tu as plus de matt wells était très
chaud cette fois ci ce mesdames deux
échecs ouest et s'est étendue sarah
salade qui a remonté un
ba qui mène au score d'ailleurs en fait
toi les scores dans les deux matchs à la
bouche et une à l'agglo et c'est serré
trois et demi trois et demi et sarah sa
date 5 4 et je pense que sarah peut se
qualifier sera dur pour jouer une
journée encore à passer deux fois un
tour si elle perd car il ya eu deux
matches sur sur cinq peut être dur elle
avait bien le match en main pourtant la
joueuse chinoise
mais bon elle c'est elle c'est elle et
elle s'est fait remonter on va voir
comment ça se passe dans le bullet 1
on va voir
il reste plus que
il reste plus que quelques minutes de
jeu plus que 10 minutes en bullet
on va voir si elle réussit à à remonter
ça va pas être facile mais c'est
possible très je pars review vite fait
non non non volovitch va peut-être un
peu récupéré quoi on fait on fait 3
heures d'échec non-stop
on va pas encore review les parties
pendant que fait une petite pause quoi
on n'est pas des ordinateurs quand même
faut être sérieux ont peu revue
n'importe quel parti qui s'éveille sur
czech comme aussi tu as aimé mais bon on
va pas tout review on peut aussi aller
review ramzan contre trop 420 kw à fin
mars contre 420 le teint gère plus
intéressant bah écoute pas sûr à
pas sûr c'est serré un ce match ils sont
serré les deux matches
les deux matches sont serrés on va voir
ce que ça donne sarah qui va qui va tout
donner pour l'emporter retourne en
demi-finale où elle devrait affronter
j'imagine kosteniuk ça c'est mathieu qui
va le savoir fait mathieu qui a le
tableau le tas les tableaux sont
tellement bizarre je peux pas les
déduire à mathieu qu'il a pas non plus
ben tu peux pas le déduire avec le
programme en fait c'est ça notre truc
marrant
c'est un autre truc marrant
elle a écrit hier genre tu veux me faire
un mail en disant quoi réviser mais
n'empêche si elle gagne ce tournoi sarah
elle peut elle peut elle a fait quoi là
dans la petite finale la dernière fois
elle a gagné où elle a perdu
est-ce que les échecs ça me gonfle ou
panne en général j'aime bien
elle s'est pris 8 2 contre l'ags noëlla
et là du coup on sait pas qui elle joue
en demie je vais essayer de regarder si
je trouve un tableau quelque part mme
jean et de te dire
est-ce que les tableaux annoncé les
vieux tableau la grèce est terrible
c'est terrible j'essaie de trouver une
nouveau tableau mais j'ai tableau des
autres et c'est tard il en fait les
tableaux avais tu peux pas bien voir f
c'est terrible ok ça y est le tableau
elle jouerait contre uni fans
ben hogan enchaînerait des jouets
chinois ce quoi bon mais faisable
imbattable uni fans
qu'elle dépasse ça ou chez nina et
vacataires de toute façon c'est mort non
elle avait pas fait un super premier
grand prix le deuxième a fait que
troisième
peut-être kosteniuk qui peut
tu as bien pas fait dans la dentelle
ouais mais chuck greene c'est touré en
fait non contre ou yifan voilà toutes
ses chances elle a toutes ses chances le
faut déjà pas se battre joue pour aller
jusqu'en finale du coup et demain sera
commentée par fab et andrea et dimanche
aussi
on va voir comment comment se passe
cette série de bulles est donc il
faudrait qu'elle gagnerait 2 1 si elle
gagne deux parties normalement allez
c'est reparti sarah sa date avec les
pièces blanches contre joue auncun alors
des quatre cavaliers f3 et b6 à a rejoué
la même variante est ce que ça va
rejouer le même truc à base de foie si
soit et c'est reparti dame b 3 mai mais
c'est pas tout à fait la même variante
que tout à l'heure
parce qu'après pions prendre puis on
prend fou bessette la dame sera plus en
en c2 ce qui était le cas tout à l'heure
alors là est ce qu'elle va jouer
cavalier c3 pour en force et puis
essayer de jouer avec 4 c'est ce qu'on
imagine un côté est côté blanc côté
sarah way carré les c3 elle protège le
pion et puis elle va pouvoir jouer le 4
pour pour englué le fou bessette dans la
chaîne de pions et peut-être menacé de5
alors là il ya peut-être des fous b 5
échecs maintenant à la fff karat sur flu
g7 et afu b5 qui fait mal à mon avis car
les 17 jours est fou prend des six
ça a l'air d'être terrible pour pour la
jouer chinoise wei foo b5 jouer
maintenant est ce que roy et fuite va
être va être réalisée ou irois f8
peut-être maintenant à 4 way pour bien
tenir la casse b5 calvar ok elle va
préparer eux 5 tout en douceur sarah le
fou qui va sûrement recouler en recul et
en en trois allez peut-être des petits
coups de à 5 maintenant pour aller
mettre un petit coup de butoir menaces
et peut-être des à 6 pouces et 6 aussi
ou des abbés el mellah tour en 1
la tour en d1 elle se prépare mais
laisse un peu le l'esprit l'esprit libre
noir qui réussit à se ré 1 qui
réussissent à se réorganiser à l'ap a
joué le coup vraiment pour faire mal
elle réorganise simplement ces pièces
sarah salat
elle remet le cavalier en c4 elle s'en
prend pions des six qui avaient lieu 5
on a l'impression que joua jun a réussi
à stabiliser la position bon an mal an
et que maintenant bon la chose iranienne
a toujours l'avantagé mais c'est - - - -
visible cavale et h5 peut-être le fou
qui va venir en 5 un jeu sur cases
noires qui arrive c'est en train de
tourner les amis c'est en train de
tourner et ça tourne ça tourne plutôt
côté côté chinois maintenant à présent
la chinoise qui a bien replacer ces
pièces qui en font eux cinq puissant un
cavalier h5 elle a des idées de
cavaliers f4 maintenant aussi
pour pour jouer sur le clouage la dame
qui vient le fou qui va repartir vers
ces huit le fou blanc au le fond blanc
qui s'échangera ça c'est étonnant les
amis le fond blanc qui s'échangent et
les noirs qui réussissent maintenant à
se replacer à 200% peut-être un cavalier
qui va venir en f4 tôt ou tard ou
cavaliers g7 f5 aussi qui peut être un
implant pour la joueuse chinoise joueuse
chinoise qui a l'air plus à l'aise dans
cette structure de pions mais la
connexion de la joueuse chinoise est
légèrement défaillante on va voir si
elle peut jouer fc1 quoi et c'est fait
ouais j'ai envie de dire que je joue à
une joue n'a dominé vraiment
stratégiquement cette partie de a à z et
maintenant elles menacent cavaliers
pranger 3 à g dames français deux
séparés mais il ya peut-être il ya des
carabistouilles là qui arrive côté côté
noir il va y avoir du g4 qui va partir à
l'essai g4 côté blanc justement ça
l'empêchent mais le cavalier qui vient
en d4 ça va c'est changer on va voir si
la joueuse iranienne réussi à résister
et qu'elles prouvent qu'elles existent
mais ça va perdre le pion dessins que ça
va faire un pion plus cotés
côté chinois la joueuse chinoise qui est
bien qui est qui à fond qui a un pion
plus maintenant gpro f4 qui va arriver
la case 2 1 qui va qui va s'allumer un
côté est côté noir
attention il ya peut-être des tours
problème 5 qui aurait pu être joué la
tour e 1
mais tours f1 va tout défendre la
baraque la baraque iranienne qui est
défendu tour 4 pas possible adam prend
le fou qui est sous pression maintenant
tour f8 elle attaque le cavalier tour f1
elle revient tour f 7 h 3 allez on va
voir si elle peut maintenant envoyer les
mobylettes non les mobylettes qui
partent pas la dame f6 allait peut-être
un cavalier 3 maintenant avec une
enfilade non c'est pas jouer ça ça joue
très vite la côté iranien tour f 6 baies
3 h 5 peut-être qu'il va partir non la
joueuse chinoise un petit peu timorés
cavaliers prend dame prend aux quatre
cavaliers pros eux quatre tours f3
maintenant qui va partir côté chinois
tour d'essai 3g 6 non sa part le fou qui
va venir en des cas tels faits un échec
assez courageux pour prouver trop elle
perd une pièce la joueuse chinoise qui
est en train de de craquer la tour qui
part aux 7,3 g 6 tours prend 1,7 mais
y'a tout reprend 1,4 à l'essai pas
encore finie la joueuse chinoise qui va
récupérer le pion g4 non c'est pas fait
il ya trois pions passé liées face ou là
le réseau de matches qui arrivent
cavalia
oh non c'est pas vu y avait qu un
alliage 5 tours j'ai sept matches on a
vu la chinoise faire un petit rictus
elle avait vu le mat pour l'iranienne
mais il n'a pas été réalisé et
maintenant c'est le pion acquis par le
pion cki par ol avait elle a joué ses
trois d'affilée depuis en un pour éviter
g5
mais il ya des réseaux de matelas qui
arrive avec tours c'est 7 3 et 6 ans la
chinoise capitan la chinoise qui perd
elle est tombée la joueuse chinoise non
elle n'est pas tombée
ça joue encore il ya eu un lag côté
commentateurs aussi le pion qui par le
pion à de la tourasse 7b 4b trois tours
j'ai deux ça va revenir à fond c'est
très très chaud les amis cavaliers trois
échecs cavaliers trois échecs qui a le
dernier mot b2g 8 dan il va y avoir un
drame mais maintenant il va y avoir une
mère d'échecs qui va permettre
probablement à sarah sa date de
l'emporter tour d'essai 3e 4 et là de
petits dame ces quatre matins non c'est
pas mal encore wave 3 incroyable le roi
qui s'en échappe la tour qui vient roi
f2 dame échec 3e 1 tour 3 roy f1 dans
me2 roi géant dames d'alger de maths et
qui a valu aux cavaliers de matisse y
est c'est terminé extrêmement importante
la victoire de sarah sadate une partie
où on est passé par toutes les émotions
les amis et finalement c'est sarah
sadate qui s'impose dans une partie qui
a vraiment duré et ce qui veut dire
qu'il y aura que trois parties maximum
sarah sadate qui a deux balles de match
à 6 si la joueuse iranienne ne fait une
nulle un simplement c'est sûr qu'elle
qu'elle remportera ce match c'est
vraiment un duel au sommet entre entre
les deux femmes et sarah sadate qui est
vraiment bien revenu dans le match
attention elle a joué cette variante
delà de la catalane y avait une partie
je pense importante entre great choqué
et nakamura dans cette variante mais ça
se passe pas trop mal pour la joueuse
iranienne pour le mangent pas que ce
cavalier b6 ici le coup pour revenir
mettre la pression et éventuellement sur
le cavalier c4 la joueuse chinoise qui
prend en c5 ça échange en c4 alors
peut-être fois-ci 6,6 raté par la
joueuse chinoise qui donne la qualité
ont elles fait l'écart la maman sarah sa
date c'est vraiment une balle de match
ici qu'à la dame c'est cette france et 5
ça va arriver
ouais
elle fait l'écart 1 ses qualités de plus
dans une position assez assez simple
finalement est simplement une nul lui
suffit pour l'emporter il faut assurer
le coup maintenant côté iranien pour se
qualifier une deuxième fois en
demi-finale et défendre ses chances face
à la numéro un mondiale ou ifan allait
peut-être un petit coup de dames bessède
protège le fou attaque 4 et du coup ça
permettra de faire d'éventuelles
découvertes dame bessette paraît bon
elle fait dame b 8 tout aussi jouable
mais peut-être un peu moins saignant b4
joué par la joueuse chinoise qui
attaquent le cavalier maintenant qu'il y
aurait pu partir on a 6 1 pour attaquer
le pion mais elle part vers 17 la tour
qui arrive en baisse est elle en train
de se mettre le feu la sara sadate en
l'espace de quelques coups l'aller les
blancs se sont complètement activer le
cavalier qui va partir en bessin qu'il
ya des fous 3,7 qui menace il va
peut-être un retour prend des 8 es fou
prend à 7 et ça fera deux pions pour la
qualité peut-être fou prend à 7 ans
premier impair permettait de d'enfermer
la dame en a 8 mai elle veut prendre du
cavalier ce qui est pas idiot et menacé
cavaliers c6 aller maintenant
sarah sadate qui met la tourner en d1
qui cloue le fou en f1 le pion qui
parent b5 lecavalier en d6 là c'est très
très chaud là la partie cavaliers c6 la
dame noire complètement fermée dans les
22 mètres de sarah sa date peut-être un
roi qui va partir en g2 rapidement pour
ceux des clous libéré finalement ce fou
ou bien un coup comme dame b3 aussi
envisageable attaque la tour
la tour qui va partir en est maintenant
peut-être un coup comme dam des trois
noms elle fait ou 5 sur quel point ça
sur france 5 à la cavalier prend 1,5
elle a tout vu et l'a joué chinois d'un
qui affluent en plus une fourchette je
m'en étais pas rendu compte
là elle va avoir une tour maintenant
elle à quoi elle sait que c'est quoi le
matériel ici il faut compter un peu les
pièces ya de quoi il ya trois pièces et
deux pions il ya deux pièces et deux
pions contre contre la tour le pion qui
parent b6 dame france est si sûre et
bessette
maintenant il ya peut-être un petit coup
de wake cavaliers à 5 pour faire
bessette aux contres menaces sur un
média dame beisheim tranquille la
joueuse chinoise qui défend et surtout
prend 1,5 à bessette le pion b est
inarrêtable ça va faire un partout dans
les bulles est sarah sadate qui a
toujours un point d'avancé sur jouait
john et et maintenant c'est la dernière
balle de match pour sarah sadate qui
doit ap
so lu ment absolument les amis faire une
nulle alors sarah sadate qui répètent la
même ouverture que tout à l'heure avec
des quatre c4 cavagnac 3 lecavalier qui
va partir en c3 en a trois pour éviter
fou b4 le fou qui part en baisse est le
cavalier qui vient en c3 qui va menacer
4 la dame qui va arriver en c2 qui va
qui va préparer le coup eux quatre avec
le fou qui va venir en d3 ou bien le
coup des 5 tout à fait jouable aussi
pour en mesurer ce fou c'est un petit
peu la même structure que tout à l'heure
mais améliorée quand même pour les noirs
qui ont perdu moins de temps alors elle
va jouer des 6 e 5 c'est une structure
de type est indienne et ça en bullet ça
peut être intéressant un cavalier qui va
peut-être partir en 17 ans et ce à un
coût en 17 ans et 5 ans à 6
il va il va viser la casse est sain qui
va viser le pion cas et ses cinq
attaques car il va y avoir f3 il va y
avoir le pion qui va partir en a4 les
noirs ont une position intéressante
peut-être à venir ces très hauts blancs
ici cavaliers detroit jouer elle
anticipe cette idée mais car elle et ses
cinq salles échangeant ses 5 et les
noirs qui vont faire cavalier 85 et
qu'ils vont tout envoyé ouais on bulle
est là avec peu de temps à la pendule
c'est quand même plutôt intéressant pour
la joueuse chinoise
la joueuse chinoise qui maintenant va
envoyer la marée de pions avec f 5 1 qui
arrive avec 5 à venir peut-être un petit
coup de fouet aux trois premiers noms
elf f5 direct elle va préparer f4 ça va
faire très très mal les amis on pourrait
vivre une égalisation à delajoux et
chinoises dans les derniers instants de
ce match c'est la dernière partie du
match il ya toujours un point d'avancé
pour pour sarah sa date mais le pion qui
arrivant j'ai six f4 est à tout le monde
va jouer à l'est le roi la partie va
être extraordinaire là les amis il ya
beaucoup de jeux pour les pour les deux
joueuses avaient droit peut-être cavaler
g7 pour rejaillir éventuellement vers
vers f5 une dame qui peut partir en
dix-sept les tours qui pourront être
doublé mais il faut jouer vite à un côté
côté chinois 10 secondes d'avancé pour
pour la joueuse chinoise shuai joue une
fois çi ce qui vient clouer le cavalier
allait peut-être dame 17 essayé de faire
tout retour f7 tour f8 c'est un peu
l'idée l échange elle même en d3 étrange
mais elle veut tout reprend f1 avec
cavaliers f5 elle veut se des clous et
attaquer le fourrage 6 qui va repartir
en d2 et peut-être un coup après comme
fou g5 pour échanger le mauvais fou
contre le bon fou à elle va jouer pour
le fou en d4 et maintenant la joueuse
chinoise kim est vraiment la pression à
la dame qui va arriver en hausse est la
tour en 1 8es ça va presser tout de
suite chez chez l'adversaire g4 jouer
il va y avoir peut-être il ya peut-être
un problème les amis il ya peut-être un
problème de dame prend des quatre
cavaliers six mois c'est terrible c'est
terrible les amis c'est terrible la
joueuse la joueuse chinoise en sueur où
elle a vu dame prend des quatre
cavaliers f6 qui arrive on s'est
terminée c'est terminé les amis
cavalière six échecs roi c'en est fini
des histoires désespoir de djoua joon ho
puis là ça fait mal hein y'a pois
chiches damev huit ans a fait très mal
fois six dames et fuite imparable hall a
joué chinoise qui perd là dessus à ces
dérives
c'est terrible c'est terrible sarah
sadate qui l'emportent
sarrassat qui remporte ce match alors
que dans l'autre match je crois bien vu
la caméra que c'est katia l'acno qui
l'emportait c'est terrible à cinq
partout dans l'autre match
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible on va avoir le droit d'aider
partage dans l'autre dans l'autre quart
de finale extraordinaire sarah sarah
très heureuse et on va le voir le droit
à des add partage dans l'autre match les
amis extraordinaire ouais c'est terrible
c'est terrible un pur pour ça pour jouer
jun pardon et à la bouche et inaki au
bord des larmes elle a de nouveau au
bord de la crise de nerfs sur la caméra
vous la voyez pas encore on va laisser
le truc se recadrer on va récupérer les
cameramans en compte comme il faut
jean-michel cadrage
au bord de la crise de nerfs hanau chez
nina qui a complètement suez
alors on va récupérer on va mettre hanau
chez nina encore des départageant dans
ces matchs très serrés et uniquement si
on veut que sarah pas sur la chaîne iii
e mail par le elle parle français ou pas
c'est le papa français s'est compliqué
quoi
c'est compliqué quand on lui apprend le
français mathieu on est bilingue ouais
je vois on n'est pas bilingue y tient on
va voir les matchs les matches qui sont
pas finis en faut qu'on se mette de quel
côté on se met delà du côté
douchez nina en fait
alors on va voir on va voir ce que ça
donne l'ultime match de la journée les
départage là qui vont faire plaisir
bref on fera un vote un poussoir si les
gens veulent que sarah sadate vienne
vienne sur le live fera un vote mais
j'aurai donc vous allez vouloir qu'elle
passe quand même moi je suis trilingue
way
maj parle trois langues
vingt quatre bien sûr on sait de quoi il
parle
par ses bons alors une petite blague là
après trois mois ça fait trois heures
vingt de livevault le 3 heures la jeune
aura une petite blague quand même quand
même on a le droit à prêt après trois
heures de live dans ce tournoi à faire
cette petite blague un petit peu bof
quand même le droit coire est calme le
droit on est français bordel lobby
charkia pas compris non mais assez
normal ne les mineurs non non pas de nom
pas con non pas à comprendre cette
blague c'est une blague c'est une blague
pour adultes
les blagues pour adultes c'est pour les
adultes et comprennent alors on arrive
dans dans dance et des partages de ce
match qu'on n'a pas suivi un les matches
serrés hanau chez nina qui a fait
finaliste d'un tournoi perdante
enfin elles étaient finalistes et
gagnantes d'un autre donc elle est
vraiment très bien placées contre katyal
avec nos championnes du monde deux
parties blitz donc ça ça joue quand même
très bien
ça joue quand même très bien des deux
côtés katia qui était une des grandes
favorites un de ces grands prix fidh
mais anna ou chez nina qui s'est montrée
qui s'est montrée dangereuse et on va
voir dans ce match c'est ici katia
réussi à mettre à mal anna je crois
l'avait battu dans dans d'autres matches
un à auchy nadon qui a choisi la défense
russe la petrov et qui a une position
plutôt égal parce que la pollution
regarder aller symétrique au centre les
amis et les positionnements des pièces
est plutôt symétrique donc katyal
haguenau qui n'a rien obtenu pour le
moment mais qui a un petit avantage à la
pendule une trentaine d'une 20 25
secondes au premier intermédiaire et ça
peut ça peut faire la différence alors
maintenant un haouch et nina qui s'est
mis sur la colonne c'est pour pour
attaquer le fou c'est de le fou qui
revient en d3 et maintenant cavalier e 4
qui semble donner un pion mais on va
obtenir énormément d'activités avec avec
les noirs aller du tout avec des huit du
fou qui va venir on arrive c'est un coup
en d5 le foin f6 et ça va être vraiment
très menaçants peut-être f6 dame b6
j'aime bien aussi
elle attaque le pion maintenant fut f6
et on va mitrailler le le pion le pion
des quatre on pourra rajouter encore
fous des 5 fu prend f3 et hanau chenil à
qui va récupérer ce pion mais qui a
toujours un retard à la pendule donc la
position qui est à mon avis complètement
égal mais mais mais comme vous le voyez
il ya 25 secondes d'avancé pour la
joueuse russe sur l'ukrainienne et ça ça
peut faire une énorme différence
évidemment le temps dans ses positions à
la pollution est vraiment à la ccim et
reach est symétrique un regard de la
structure de pions c'est exactement la
même les fous de couleurs opposées
il ya juste un petit nombre mais rien
est un petit passement de pièces
différents mais mais il n'y a pas pas de
vraies différences dans cette position
simplement il ya peut-être les blancs
qui souhaite ramener une dame en 5 mais
voilà dame qui vient aussi ça propose
échange il ya deux parties je vous le
rappelle c'est un mini match là en deux
parties est ce que katia va échanger les
dames et faire nul ou est ce qu'elle va
gagner attention quand même un pour
katia qui perd petit à petit son son
avantage autant la loi qui va venir en
aide cette fois f5 tour ces deux c'est
quand même nul de chez nul je vois pas
l'une des deux joueuses l'emporter mais
ma foi qui c'est un sous la pression du
temps tout peut arriver tour 17 ans à
serment une proposition de nuls tacite
accepté par par katia on va pas en voir
beaucoup plus sain dans cette partie
faussée 6 7 3 on va rester à g iii mais
bon il va y avoir du h5 g6 f5 on va
rester sur surduts symétrique il va pas
se passer grand chose les amis la salle
idées pour être de provoquer ouais non
mes moyens pas ouais a6b 5 et essayer
roi c5
bon elle réussit à faire un petit
quelque chose quand même une petite
pression quand même côté à côte et katia
faut essayer de faire un genre de zoug
langnau est fou c'est 5 fu b4 aller
revient en c7 est fou c'est cinq
peut-être à nom est là oui elle peut le
faire comme ça aussi mais là ya cinq ans
à 5 à 4,1 pouces et 5 fu bekkat
peut-être c'était une idée mais la 5 à 4
et c'en est fini des micros idée de
gains la joie ni l'une ni l'autre
l'emporté
la proposition nul de katia accepté par
anna et tout va se jouer maintenant les
amis alors hanau chez nina qui va
reprendre son système de londres katia
qui joue avec g6 et san roque elle l a
pas fait l émeut les mêmes erreurs un
peut-être que les autres joueuses de
laisser entrer dans le système de
londres l'a peut-être des camaïeux 4
mais ça devait pas et peut-être des
dames b 4 échecs qui l'empêchait en tout
cas hanau chez nina qui connaît bien ces
petits systèmes et qui réussit à ceux à
se placer avec son double fiant qu'eto'o
le rock etc des positions qu'elle joue
très bien avec les blancs c'est vraiment
sur ses positions laquelle aura
construit généralement les victoires en
matches et c'est pas une surprise de la
voir réutiliser un ce genre de sites
même dans la partie décisive du match
puisque je vous le rappelle
en cas de victoire de l'une des deux
joueuses le match sera terminée donc
c'est la partie vraiment décisive à leur
réussissent c'est pour jouer pour des 5
ou a6b 5 par la suite c'est ce qu'on
appelle un système de type hérisson
j'ai envie de te dire ça pique pour pour
la joueuse ukrainienne qui va devoir
faire face aux poils hérissés de de
katia dans cette partie alors manon hull
échange des fous deux cases blanches
il va falloir faire attention à vie pour
les blancs sur sur se fiant kétou mais
il ya peu de peu de pièces pour venir
attaquer côté noirs et les blancs qui
prennent l'espace un manant regarder
tous les pions blancs qui sont placés
sur casse blanche et les blancs qui ont
gardé leur fou de cases noires donc qui
font l'effort mais on a pris beaucoup d
espace et les noirs vont éventuellement
contrer en plus katyal haguenau qui
maintenant à 30 secondes d'avancé à la
pendule sur sur un house chez nina et
qui a réussi petit à petit a augmenté la
pression elle réussit à jouer tempo elle
a vraiment l'air d'être en zone de
confort
et c'est maintenant qu'elles commencent
juste pour la première fois de la partie
a marqué un petit temps d'arrêt mais
mais pas très long elle a perdu que dix
secondes l échange les pièces est-ce que
ça va échanger encore avec dame eu trois
cavaliers eux deux un côté côté blanc ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'on commence à a
placé la dame en rose 3 attention à ce
pas se prendre un rouage cette fois ci
ça elle a fait foi à 6 tours ces deux va
être joué et à tour des 4 et le fou qui
va revenir angers 7 tours d2 et skull
est-ce que ça va répéter non katia qui
veut pas deux nuls qui veut qui veut
vraiment profiter de ces trente secondes
avance et maintenant il va falloir que
cana ou chez nina accélère à la plus de
12 secondes noces et dangereuse que fait
un haouch et nina dans cette partie elle
se décide finalement pour cavaliers b un
mail avantage là est complètement pour
katia 1 38 secondes avance maintenant
hanau chez nina qui est vraiment très
lente dans cette partie il va falloir
qu'elle produise son effort à ce moment
là elle a plus le temps de niaiser là
attention le pion qui part en d5 pour
katia ça échange la dame qui va arriver
à eux cinq tours des 4 allez il faut
cahier des six cavaliers
5la faut aller jouer les cases à
l'écueil c'est simple c'est pas mal on
joue la case de 6 elle va réussir à
envoyer son pion plus de quatre secondes
pour 4 secondes pour le craignent n o
c'est incroyable à quel point il s'est
mise mal autant au cas l'erreur de la
joueuse d'ukrainiens
d'avoir autant autant autant attendu
c'est incroyable et il va falloir
maintenant de toujours et tempo ça
paraît ça paraît quand même compliqué là
pour la joueuse ukrainienne qui enchaîne
quand même là le cas et c'est de créer
des cas très bien joué et on prend des
quatre tempo elle est solide quand même
un solide sur ses appuis
maintenant elle attaque le pion des cinq
à l'attack b4 est là elle a réussi quand
même à sortir d'un mauvais plis et en
maintenance et katia qui n'a plus de 20
secondes
oh c'est incroyable c'est en train de se
retourner katia qui a complètement perdu
la main de la position et yahoo chez
nina qui a placé une accélération
fulgurante fulgurante les amis la tong
qui va venir en d2 le camp des saints
katia qui qui est en train de perdre un
temps précieux aussi hanau chez nina
réussi à maintenir un tel rythme elle va
elle va l'emporter
katia qui essayent de retourner la
situation rentrant sur la première
hausse est incroyable d'une attaque de
maths maintenant il ya tout en gérant
les amis roi f3 n'en rouages de tours h
un rouage et à tours damien leroy qui
repart en f3 à tour h 3o assez terrible
c'est terrible adam qui va venir en f2
n'en la tour eiffe de damages saintonge
et de satyam justesse il faut trouver le
killer la tour e il ya toutes les pièces
ton retour f1 il ya toutes les pièces de
katia qui sont là la dame qui tombe
la tour qui va venir ou h de salaire
d'être finies les amis c'est
l'élimination là pour la joueuse
ukrainiennes ont leur la ola dam d'un
point à 2 et c'est fini les amis à une
dame de plus katia qui peut pas rater ça
les anime elle réfléchit à quoi le pense
non non c'est juste un lag hausse est
incroyable c'est incroyable tu peux pas
rater ça la côte est côté noir fois les
raser le pion g3 le pion h4 et et
envoyer les pions mais il n'y a plus
aucune chance là pour prochaine inaki
qui va qui va qui va finalement
s'incliner 1 face à katia voilà c'est
impossible de passer les amis à le pion
h qui va j'ai envie de dire là il ya eu
un moment vraiment compliqué dans le
match pour pour katia mais là là ça va
le faire maintenant h 4 h 3 h 2 ça ça
avance ou alors qu'elle panique quand
même un petit peu en là faut faut quand
même qu'elle ferme qu'elle ferme la game
on sent on sent un coup de panique un
côté katia je suis en train de d'avoir
peur pour elle elle en voit pas les
pions cas ce qu'elle fait moi ça a l'air
d'aller quand même mais mais elle me
fait peur et elle se fait peur aux dames
c4 d'impro f7 c'était game
asetek
les amis à les fonds envoyés de pions la
côte et katia sais c'est pas si phoenix
haye a plus que six secondes les amis je
sais plus quoi commenté ça va ça à faire
perpète
oh c'est incroyable comment je gagne pas
avec une date de plus haut c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable dame net de plus ça gagne pas
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible
ah c'est terrible ah c'est pas possible
les avis aux c'est pas possible de ne
pas gagner avec une dame de plus c'est
terrible oh là là là là haut la
catastrophe la catastrophe les amis
d'anne est de plus
damned de plus 13 secondes puis sunna la
pendule au c'est incroyable de rater sa
hausse est terrible championne du monde
de blitz merde quand même
oh c'est terrible c'est terrible pas
manger weppes a pas mangé pas poussé le
courage c'est terrible c'est incroyable
ça incroyable c'est sérieux c'est
terrible je pensais pas que c'était
possible
c'est terrible
tel geste style avec quand même
enfin elle a bien joué jusque là quoi
vais-je a raté ça c'est terrible
ces crimes terribles ne pas gagner ça
puisse aller mieux au temps quoi tu
prends h4 déjà pourquoi prendre f4
comprend pas en fait tu perds juste un
temps est maintenant temps voit quoi
même là tu laisses la dame ambiguïté
t'envoie il peut rien t'arriver en fait
et la dame c4 quand même hélas h4 quoi
crois tu fais chèque en fait je m'en bat
suède fait juste h4 c'est terrible
car élèves dès 16h 25e
abb 4
mais encore 1,5 mais sérieux c'est
terrifiant quoi bon aller c'est le
cheetah pas mon truc
donc c'est reparti pour pour cette
partie sur les lieux afin oui je vais
bien reposé ce soir de créer à la mi
temps je lui ai dit c'est bon ça va pas
finir trop tard et finalement le match
qui ignore les amis donc les règles de
cette partie hanau chez nina à 5 minutes
qu'at t a line on en a quatre donc une
minute de plus pour push et nina les
blancs sont obligés de gagner en cas de
nul c'est kata qui sera qualifié on va
voir mais c'est terrible mais elle a
bien fait de pas abandonner ou chez nina
mais c'est incroyable quand même on en a
vu des choses dans les animés
on en a vu des choses voilà lé avantage
psychologique 1 doit être du côté de la
joueuse ukrainienne mais depuis ce
carrément fernand c'est une minute c'est
juste humide de plus pour justifier
qu'ils sont obligés de gagner avec les
blancs c'est l'armageddon sens bruce
willis dans cette même formation type
hérisson un pour les noirs les blancs
qui vont peut-être tentés allez faut
envoyer sur le roi bim
il y en a marre attaque d'où vient ce
nom armageddon est mais c'est ça vient
du film servir du film et dames deux
têtes h3 f4 ou f4 h3 prendre de l'espace
faut jouer vite info faut mettre sous
pression n'y a pas de rajout de temps un
an c'est armageddon ce que l'échangé
avait été femme à avoir lé parti sont
longues fantôme y à 2 88 change de dame
était pavée peut-être une logique 1 pour
aller vers la nulle mais bon à savoir
aussi que quand tu rates dames trois
pions contre tours pions j'ai envie dire
rien ne t'assure une nulle 1 j'ai envie
je retiens rien de ta sur la nulle sénat
qui semble avoir pleuré je sais pas elle
a l'air d'être au bord de la crise de
nerfs à chaque fois hanau chez nina fort
qu elle monte sa position à gauche et
nina la forêt regard faut pas se mettre
à mal autant il n'y a pas une seconde de
rage ou l x 3 c'est pas mal elle s'en
prend au pion aux pions des six hanau
chez nina qui met la pression petit à
petit qui augmente la pression sur des
six paires dans des fous prend des six
parfois qui qui rôdent du coup et
peut-être tourné trois tours tournée on
peut être d'am dam de aérien autour des
3 tours ces deux j'aime bien il va
peut-être avoir dames 3 tout cas les
jouets ce qu'ils sont solides
mentalement parce qu'après avoir raté un
truc
ça c'est difficile de se remettre dedans
moi j'aurais bien envie de faire acheter
attache c1 quand même un peu on voit
quoi présente toi là c'est difficile 1
pour un haouch et ina qui commence à se
mettre mal autant j'ai peur pour ou chez
nina qui se met quand même un peu trop
mal autant à mon goût dans ces parties a
pas le plus sain comme je vous disais hé
hé avoir l'option du flag en fin de
partie on armageddon avec les blancs
c'est plutôt intéressant et j'en ai à
bien h quatre là avec les blancs
vraiment il faut il faut que tu envoies
il va te restait plus qu'à deux minutes
déjà
elle avait rattrapé son adversaire elle
va elle va de nouveau avoir elle avait
une minute d'avancé au début elle va en
avoir une de retard très bientôt
elle cale complètement là où chez nina
ouais c'est des images terribles dans ce
tour de france
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir cavaliers
pro b 5 dame prend b5 dame prend tout
reprend tout reprend mais je pense qu'il
ya un tour à s'inquiéter tout reprend
1,2 à la fin c'est dommage mais ça se
regarde quand même il ya tête fou prend
des six aya fou prend des six cavaliers
prend dame prend dame prend tout reprend
tour prend tour à 5 fu des six tours à
deux rois h3 et aura eu 5 à la fin elle
l'a vu elle le joue haut et katia qui a
laissé cette tactique pacé direct un
crémant séduire les finales récents l'un
crémant ça va être terrible à la cata
qui a filé un pion mais qui a un peu
d'activité aller alors avec les blancs
comme en escale doit continuer b5 peut
être un coup mais là plus qu'une 30,1
pour moi hanau chez nina là ok elle a
gagné un pion elle a pris l'avantagé
mais pour moi une minute d'écart vu ce
qu'on a vu dans les high tone précédent
ça me parait ça me paraît compliqué
après on va voir j'espère pour elle
qu'elle va nous donner tort turki mais
on s'est vite à les voir repartir avec
saddam et elle pourra faire du cavalier
à 4 après là quand même un pion de plus
à une minute de retard mais pion de plus
allez vous prend et hockey benko style
les deux pions sur sur les colonnes
ouverte
il ya du jeu pour pour les noirs
évidemment mais au moins il ya l'idée de
deux gains qui est là on voyait la
marche avant par contre katia qui fait
une superbe partie pour le moment dans
dans le contrôle 1 elle est allée bien
au temps elle fait la partie qu'il faut
katia avec les noirs ici je trouve est
là elle a la mainmise sur sur l'ale dame
est là le fou g7 qui obstruent pas mal
de cases est là les pions qui
réussissent pas à avancer
son seul problème c'est qu'il faut
qu'elle trouve un coup car elle ne peut
pas bouger sinon il ya le pion qui tombe
et où la foux p2 est ce qui se passe sur
carré les deux des quatre
j'aime pas trop dame prend 1,2 et y'aura
dame eux deux elle fait tour ces deux
alors il va peut-être y avoir un échange
bizarre hein je pensais qu'ils avaient
eu des cas hélas fort le fou le fou
avait l'air de s'être un peu perdu
ok elle prend le pion c'est logique et
maintenant faut envoyer aux cinq
attaques et de l'autre côté un très
clairement cavaliers c3 de façon à
toujours damas ça sert à rien peut-être
envoyer un e 5 et créer créé
l'incertitude
ouais ou g4 c'est bien joué mais il n'y
a plus trop de temps s'était c'est
bizarre cet échange de tour qu'avait
lieu des 4 pareil c'est vraiment cool
avec le tour aux deux à l'efo faut
envoyer la hache 4 voilà c'est bien ce
qu'il fallait faire depuis tout à
l'heure
faut tout envoyer sur le roi mais la
joueuse russe semble avoir quand même
une certaine avance bon déjà la pendule
cession même sur la position à sa
position alors complètement corrects il
faut envoyer voilà c'est chose faite
maintenant pour l'ukrainienne 48
secondes elle est très mal autant il va
falloir faire la diff
j'imagine dame c5 ici pour assurer le
coup côté noir hanoi adam prend b2 je
commence à raconter n'importe quoi mais
a ouais c'est pas si facile à jouer un
prise b5
est ce qu'elle va faire g5 même j'ai
cinq possibles 1 pour eux elle fait dams
et 8
elle va créer le bordel là bas leroy qui
vient elle va sûrement reprendre de la
dame dame prend b3 va être joué et
cavaliers f4 ouais ça va être chaud
quarante secondes contre une minute et
quelques à l'essai c'est bien joué c'est
encore de la part de katia qui se blinde
il n'y a pas trop trop d' attaque pour
le moment je pense j'ai ça y va être
joué mais j'ai l'impression katia quand
même a quand même des armes à faire
valoir avec une dame qui peut venir en
b2
un fou qui pourra revenir aux 5 ça a
l'air les amis de plutôt bien tenir un
côté russe c'est solide
c'est c'est très solide même elle va
prendre du cavalier j'imagine essayer de
poussage 5 h 6 attention à la jme
l'ukrainienne qui n'a plus que 28
secondes et elle va se prendre les
échecs là attention pas d'âme 5 il ya
cavaliers g6 elle le voit à roigé katia
d'âme des uns royal ya des idées de
perpète la côte et roya cavalière six
échecs n'y avait qu'à relief 6 qui
étaient quasiment tous les amis ça a été
raté elle a raté un match en un mais
mais allez allez toujours dans la game
elle a toujours une grosse avance il
faut pas faut pas perdre de temps là
ouais c'était échecs vont y avait il ya
vait dame pro f 6 mais bon elle a raté
un gadin un gain de dames en 1 mais elle
a toujours davantage à la pendule
s'assemblent ça semble aller tout à fait
aller revient à m6 avec le cavalier
répète les coups ça te fait gagner le
match
wells est en train de répéter là ça se
passe bien pour pour katia aller à
l'envoi le pion h5 maintenant c'est sa
seule chance le fou qui vient aux cinq
dames f5 le retour elle va refaire un
cavalier f6 a laissé bien fou prend fkt
change tout et un roi g8 trois sets
c'est terminé les amis c'est terminé ça
va ça va se qualifier la côte est côté
katia qui prend le pion à 6 allez c'est
fini c'est fini les amis c'est gagné
pour pour katia même même si elle
tombait avec avec les noirs n'y a plus
assez de matériel c'est fini victoire de
katia
malgré avoir raté maintes et maintes
occasions surtout le dames trois pions
contre tours ce qui était dommage mais
finalement elles l'emportent elles
éliminent hanau chez nina qui ne verra
pas les demi finales et donc katia qui
rencontrera alexandra kosteniuk pour un
superbe match demain et sarah sat qui
jouera contre contre où il fane l'autre
chinoise
donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant et j'ai envie de vous
dire on se retrouve
on se retrouve à vous vous retrouverez
pas bien et et andrea demain sur les
coups de 15h30 durée 1h je crois que je
commence une heure plus tard pour la
suite de la compétition et les demi
finales un grand merci à vous d'avoir
suivi et à et je vous dis je vous dirai
ce soir pour le sahb battle ciao ciao